[Music]
to Technology Day 2008 edition and I'd
also like to welcome all the folks
watching on the web increasingly we're
able to offer this program not only here
in Kresge but to the MIT community
around the world so welcome to all of
you technology day is the annual
symposium that is organized by an alumni
committee for your intellectual pleasure
in between all of the parties that you
have during reunion week we know you
like to have a few moments of a little
bit of hard thinking and also a chance
to see some of the exciting work that's
going on with today's faculty and
students the Technology Day committee if
you would stand I'd like to thank you
for your work this year
and on behalf of the committee I have to
thank Lou Alexander who's on this staff
of the MIT Alumni Association he runs
this committee and makes our job
extremely easy and he was also
responsible for the wonderful video that
we had running both here and on the web
as the introduction to the program so
Lou thank you to you for all the hard
work you do on behalf now I'd like to
say everyone cell phones pagers
noisemakers turn them off or down that's
always the first announcement thank you
very much and our program today our
theme is called out of this world
and I humankind has always had an
interest in the heavens and the world
outside of Earth and today our first two
speakers are gonna help us understand
that world max tegmark is going to talk
about cosmology and our current
understanding of our place in space and
then professor David Newman is going to
talk about humans in space and human
exploration of space and then our final
speakers Cynthia Brazil is going to
bring us back to Earth and introduce us
a little bit to the parallel world of
robots so we have a very exciting
program and I'm sure each of these
speakers could talk all day but we're
gonna try to limit them to about 35
minutes so we have some time for
questions and this year we're gonna go
back to the old fashioned method of
collecting questions on index cards
those of you who have been to tech day
in the past or other events with MIT
alums know that there's a bad habit of
asking questions turning into long
pontificating speeches where it's hard
to figure out where the question
actually is so this year the usher is
about five minutes before the scheduled
and of the speaker's presentations the
ushers will quietly walk through the
aisles and collect cards so write your
questions as you think them pass them to
the edges and that will make it easier
for the ushers to collect them and then
during the Q&A time we'll also if you
have questions on cards the ushers will
come and get
we'll do a little bit of vetting and
organizing of the questions and do a
little structured Q&A that way let's see
okay so with that I think that's the end
of the preliminaries and it's my great
pleasure to introduce Beth Garvin
currently the executive vice president
and CEO of the MIT Alumni Association
but soon-to-be former CEO she has just
accepted a job at Brown and will be
heading them Oh whizzy whizzy oh sorry
sorry
Oh RISD that other School in Providence
and we're very excited for her although
very sad to see her leave the MIT Alumni
Association so Beth
well good morning it is always my
pleasure at this event to officially
welcome you back to MIT on behalf of the
Alumni Association as we prepare for
reunions I always remind the staff that
there's a bit of a shock sometimes for
alumni as they return the campus is
quite different for many of you since
your last visit and on the staff we tend
to think about the brand new buildings
the Stata Center or Simmons Hall or the
construction that's going on seemingly
endlessly on Cambridge streets but I've
had a couple instances this week that
remind me that those aren't necessarily
the questions were going to get I had
one very frustrated alumnus asking me
earlier this week where McCormick Hall
was because you know that wasn't built
when we were here said oh yeah yeah so
we we kind of trace ash down as being a
landmark and figured out how to get
there last night someone asked me just
just remind me which one is Kresge and
you know we forget change is such a
constant here that we forget how much
this place has evolved and it reminds me
of the collective wisdom of the people
in this room you are the people who have
seen MIT evolve not just physically but
in the curriculum in the leadership in
the face of our students today and it's
wonderful to have a chance to have all
of you back here and sharing some of
that wisdom and knowledge and experience
with us at the very same time we see our
class of 2008 graduate it's a wonderful
opportunity to bring MIT together and
we're very grateful to have you here
spending some of your time with us the
community of alumni has become
increasingly connected over the years
some of that is due to the wonderful
power of our online tools but a lot of
it is just because of the personal
connections that we've been able to help
facilitate I wanted to just mention in a
couple minutes I have today about one
real transformational change I've had
the privilege to watch over the last 10
years or so
the Alumni Association we were trying
with the encouragement and pushing of
the Alumni Association Board of
Directors to find a way for alumni to
play a more meaningful role at MIT
obviously the role as donors is a
incredibly meaningful and critical to
MIT support but we wanted to find more
ways for the alumni to be mentors
advisors teachers and learner's and
Friends in the past couple years it has
been delightful to watch how some of
these new roles have emerged and become
a really powerful part of the MIT Alumni
community there are lots of examples I
could share about how this engagement
has grown but I want to just mention one
because it really came home to me
vividly yesterday the externship program
that the Alumni Association sponsors
during I ap gives students a chance to
go out into the work world with alumni
these externships might be one week they
might be three weeks some are paid some
are unpaid they're in large corporations
you might be working on a trading floor
at a major investment firm you might be
working in a startup you might be
shadowing a doctor and they have become
very meaningful to the students students
tell us how much this influences their
careers and their career choices
sometimes learning they really don't
want to go into the profession they
thought they wanted to go into but
that's a good thing to learn when you're
a sophomore rather than after you
graduate and alumni tell us how much
they enjoy having the best and the
brightest in their firms working with
them getting a chance to see what MIT is
really like today and they like the
ability to recruit recruit those
students for summer jobs and possible
placement after graduation too so it's
really a win-win for everybody this year
and this is where it came home to me
yesterday the class of 2008 set a
wonderful new record in senior gift
participation I don't want to share that
with you today that's their story for
the Tech Day lunch but from my
perspective it was just as grad a
trying to see what they chose to support
at MIT often the senior gift wants to
leave something tangible a clock a map a
fountain in Killian Court they all want
a fountain in Killian Court and we sort
of have two gay guide them to something
that might be sustainable lasting and
this year on their own the students came
up with the idea of supporting creating
a fund to support students during IEP
externships for those externships that
aren't paid they wanted to make sure
that students had the opportunity to go
do the things they really wanted to do
to connect with alumni to get an
experience outside the classroom that
was meaningful and to me that just
brings this community together in a new
and wonderful way and just shows the
power of all of you in this room to
influence the future so I could talk for
hours about wonderful examples but
you're here to hear from the amazing
faculty I'm here to welcome our amazing
alumni enjoy the day and I look forward
to talking to all of you thanks very
much
Thank You Beth and we wish you all the
best as you transition to RISD now it's
my great privilege to introduce Susan
Hockfield the 16th president of MIT
Susan started her career as a
neurobiologist but her leadership skills
were recognized early and she moved up
through the ranks of departmental and
then academic and then university
administration prior to coming to MIT
she was Dean of the graduate school at
Yale and then Provost we're very happy
to have her here and are excited about
the way she is leading MIT in the 21st
century she's got some remarks for you
as well and without further ado I give
you Susan Hockfield
thank you
good morning welcome to tech day you
know I was reflecting this is my fourth
reunion weekend and it's an acquired
taste I have to say the first two years
when I staggered through this incredible
compendium events all I could think of
was who the heck designed this had to
have been an engineer but I found myself
starting about the beginning of May
actually looking forward to this
firehose and it is so wonderful and so
MIT to combine commencement with
reunions and bringing everyone to campus
and as Beth has so beautifully talked
about all of these connections that are
really you know lie at the heart of MIT
so welcome back everyone it's wonderful
to see you all this morning I'm going to
try to restrain myself but those of you
who have heard me speak before you know
it's difficult what I want to do is
preserve about 10 minutes of the time I
have with you this morning for questions
and so I hope you will write questions
on those index cards because as I often
say I'm far more interested in in
addressing the questions you actually
have and the ones I imagine you might
have so the first part will be my
addressing the questions I think you
might have and but then I want to allow
enough time so I'm gonna be very brief
and giving a you know just a an overview
of where MIT is and what where we are
this year it's been a spectacular year
on campus lots of successes lots of
advances let me just tell you that the
three faculty you're going to hear from
today I could say this at any Tech day
but you know they are the superstars I
often talk about mi t--'s magic of
working all along the continuum from the
most abstract theories to the most
advanced applications and the three
faculty today really show you that
continuum in incredibly vibrant ways
David Newman who you'll hear from her
biosuit which is over there I think
there's a version that is on view at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art it will be
there until the end of August just you
know an example of how the news of
what's coming out of MIT gets around the
world
Max and David are both just back from
the world science festival you know we
have a science festival here we actually
have the first science festival in North
America here we started it last year but
we call it the Cambridge Science
Festival they did one in New York last
week we before last and they call it the
world science festival the Cambridge
needs to a better better job of
imagining ourselves as the center of the
universe we've got this the Galactic
Science Festival and this kind of you
know the news of MIT I am just delighted
when I see you know I see references to
it stories about it everywhere let me
just tell you about four fabulous
mentions of MIT in the last year there
was an article that appeared in New York
Times and the International Herald
Tribune asking a question of you know
who are in economics who are the John
Maynard Keynes and Newton Friedman's of
today and the writer took the
perspective that a lot of economics has
gone very small some of it gets to be
kind of flashy news like about you know
gambling or shopping but but the writer
was reflecting on where where are the
people who are really changing the view
of the world the way Friedman and Keynes
did and so he did a survey of leading
economists and then he said he writes is
that the runaway winner was a small
group of economists who work at the
Jamil poverty action lab at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
led by Esther Duflo and abbe Ajit
Banerjee not bad not bad that you know
Esther and Apetit are being put in the
category of Keynes and and Friedman and
actually I think the work they're doing
actually is equivalent they are
operating from a simple but quite
radical idea that they could be as
systematic in testing methods that are
designed to alleviate poverty as we are
for drug trials so they look for the
application of these huge funds in a
controlled way so they can actually
measure the outcome this is an idea that
is really catching on the Jamil poverty
action lab is flourishing has grown
enormous lis over the last several years
then OpenCourseWare I always get a
question about OpenCourseWare when I
talk to alumni it makes me feel very
proud of n MIT you know it's being
noticed by other people too Bill Gates
had a column in Fortune where he talked
about the challenge of global education
I
in India November and the challenge of
building capacity and education is so
pressed there in other parts of the
world and he cites as the model solution
OpenCourseWare where we now have 1800
almost every one of our courses online
we get emails from people around the
world for whom this has really changed
their lives now I I have to point out
that as much as Bill Gates might love
OpenCourseWare he has not gone the next
step which is to supporting
OpenCourseWare I've got to get a meeting
with him in the coming year Tom Friedman
was on campus for the celebration of
reaching our 800 courses on
OpenCourseWare in November and he is a
marvelously curious intellect and so he
roamed all over campus while he was here
to give the keynote for the
OpenCourseWare celebration and he found
his way to the vehicle design summit
some of you may have heard this this was
the brainchild of two women engineering
students a couple years ago they had the
idea of gathering the students who
previously had competed in the solar car
race to come together and collaborate
building a vehicle that will get 200
miles per gallon this has now become an
international phenomenon he titled the
his his op-ed on this particular piece
from their tagline we are the people
we've been waiting for I look at the
students today and I just say you sure
are they are the people that we've been
waiting for and they are not the kind of
people that we were when we were in
college you all know what we were doing
we were in college it was not rolling up
our sleeves and getting to work but they
are certainly rolling up their sleeves
and getting to work and then most
recently CBS Evening News is doing a
whole series on cancer I would think
mostly precipitated by Senator Kennedy's
terrible diagnosis with brain cancer and
so they are looking at the frontier of
cancer research and they have featured
cancer research going on here from Bob
Langer Sangeeta Bhatia and Phil sharp
now these last two things I talked about
I I mentioned tie into two of the big
campus initiatives and I say the two to
big campus initiatives there are
hundreds of brilliant and wonderful and
world-changing things going on on campus
but these two large initiatives have
really taken form and gained traction in
the last year so let me give you a short
update on each of them the Energy
Initiative was officially launched only
a year and a half ago it is you know
raging through campus like a you know
some kind of storm about 15 percent of
our faculty have written white papers or
participated in some ways some way in
the energy initiative the student energy
Club has 750 members mostly graduate
students when I asked the co-presidents
what this club was about thinking of a
club in the sense is something you do as
your hobby they reminded me rapidly and
severely that the reason they're in the
club is they're going to be working in
the field so MIT is producing the future
energy pioneers the energy technologists
scientists policymakers at a rate that
is simply staggering and really quite
wonderful the initiative if I can just
kind of you know put it in in its very
short form because it reaches across
campus there are many things we're
working on not on everything but the way
we collect up the ideas is in two
different pieces we all long for that
you know the transformation the new
technologies that will power the world
and get us off fossil fuels and we're
very interested in those but those are
not going to be scaled up and ready to
use for quite a number of years so the
first part of the energy initiative is
focusing on innovations what are the
changes that we can look for this year
next year five years from now that will
improve our current technologies so
there's a lot of work in clean coal
there's a lot of work improving on
nuclear power a lot of work increasing
the efficiency of how we use power today
I like to think of efficiency as the
fifth fuel so after you know oil gas
coal and nuclear conservation is going
to be as important in meeting the
immediate challenges as any of these
technologies the second piece of the
initiative is about the transformations
and boy do we have a group a huge group
of people working on exciting
transformations solar wind waves Tide
geothermal biomass and biofuels really
doing cutting-edge breakthrough
break through work now this is a
bottoms-up activity it's not an idea I
had it's an idea the faculty student
staff and all of you also had the alumni
and so we we're allowing it to evolve
and what's evolved over the last I would
say you know probably four months was
emerged as at the centerpiece of our
Energy Initiative is solar and I am
delighted about it because I personally
view solar as you know the ultimate
technology when we can get to you know
all solar to all-electric we will be off
fossil fuels in an important way and I'm
you know some people who are not yet
converts say well why would you do solar
and it's a little bit like Willy Sutton
in the banks you know where is the money
you know where is the energy it's in the
Sun an hour of sunlight falling on the
earth it provides enough energy to power
the entire earth for a year we have got
to make better use of this particular
energy source and simply heating up
asphalt the other initiative that I want
to mention is just one piece of where
engineering the life sciences are coming
together in just amazing and powerful
ways this will be a source of changes
that will transform our lives the way
computers and the information
technologies have transformed our lives
in the 20th century one piece of that is
our new Cancer Institute it's led by
Tyler Jack's and what it brings together
are about the dozen faculty in our
Center for cancer research that have
been bringing forward the basic science
behind cancer since 1974 bringing those
faculty together with about a dozen
fabulous engineers who are thinking
about cancer because we believe that the
next most important insights about how
to diagnose treat and prevent cancer are
going to come out of this fantastic
fusion of engineering with the life
sciences I'm enormous ly optimistic
about the approach and I have to tell
you this is not theoretical it's real
and the example I give although it's
kind of a poor example against the
complexity of cancer is heart disease
the NIH invested something on the order
of four dollars a year per person in
America over 30 years in cardiac
research that's resulted in a decrease
in death
heart disease by over half what were
those advances that that permitted that
kind of decrease well they came out of
both biology and technology drugs how
many of you have heard of lipitor and
devices drug eluting stents the pioneer
for a drug-eluting stents is of course
Bob Langer who is a critical member of
our cancer initiative so bringing
together these two different
perspectives on what a problem is and
how you solve it will be very powerful
in addressing cancer the Koch Institute
for cancer research right now is a big
hole in the ground between the Ray Emery
estate a center in the Koch biology
building we hope to open that building
in 2010 now both of these initiatives
are up and running the Energy Initiative
in its first phase focused on industry
support industry partnerships that's
gone very well we've raised over a
hundred and sixty million dollars in
commitments for the Energy Initiative we
have money for about a hundred I think
over a hundred student fellows graduate
students will be working energy but for
both of these initiatives the next phase
was really going to turn to private
philanthropy as you all know I need not
remind you that federal support of
research is not what it should be in the
mid-1960s this enormous fuel for
America's innovation economy was funding
research in America at about 2% of GDP
this year it's less than 1% of GDP so we
are turning to other sources for support
of the kind of work that we believe is
critical for America to have our
leadership some of that's industry
support some of it is private
philanthropy I will give you make only
one comment about mi t--'s budget some
of you are interested in our finances
I saw Terry Stone our new executive vice
president in the audience she along with
the Provost Rafael rife Israel we Ruiz
our new vice president for finance have
done a spectacular job building a new
financial framework for MIT the budget
that we've submitted for FY o nine for
the first time in many years is balanced
we have moved to a smoothing rule for
using use of our endowment that will
reduce the volatility of endowment
payout the endowment now provides about
twenty percent of our operating costs
and half of those
costs our people and as all of you know
who run businesses on people are hard to
to move as as the economic volatility
changes particularly here at MIT where
our faculty and our students are really
the core of our enterprise we are in a
very positive track to think now very
productively about our future we have
new Dean's in many of the schools I
would say the the oldest Dean longest
standing Dean is Dell Santos who was
here just less than a year when I
arrived these new Dean's over this year
have gained traction in an incredible
way they have the confidence of their
faculty but I would say more
extraordinarily because they have all
essentially started together they are
collaborating in ways that really
haven't been seen before bringing
together the expertise from MIT Sloan
with the School of Architecture with the
schools of engineering and science so
that we can in a very serious very
unique way I believe address problems as
large as energy in the environment as
large as world poverty as large as
making a change in health care for
cancer and other diseases let me just
wrap up with a couple of very very
positive indicators this admission
seasons was as chaotic as any that
anyone has ever seen those of you who
follow this closely probably few of you
followed as closely as I do in the fall
Harvard Princeton and the University of
Virginia all stop doing early action
early admissions early of any sort
through a huge amount of uncertainty
into our admissions and then you I'm
certain have been reading about the
change in financial aid policies at
Harvard and Yale and Stanford and
Princeton actually was there several
years before those schools so we did not
know what was going to happen with
admissions I have very good news to
report the applications for MIT were up
8% again this is three years straight of
8% or greater growth in applications
this is of course makes us feel good
that so many brilliant young people want
to come to MIT but I think it's an
important message around the nation
you know we accepted you know just less
than 12% of the applications which means
these students are going to go someplace
else most of them are going to go
someplace else
but it means the students in America
around the world
are increasingly turning to science
technology and a science and technology
based way of thinking about the
humanities arts and social sciences that
MIT represents this is good news for the
country we emitted as I said just less
than 12% and our yield on those students
was just over 66% this is wonderful
in the face of all of this you know
turmoil in the admissions universe this
was not our top year but the third best
year for yield at MIT let me just talk a
little bit about our financial aid
policies for 40 years mit has been
practicing knee blind admissions
absolutely knee blind we also provide
aid that is entirely need-based we don't
provide any kind of merit-based aid many
schools in fact I would argue that most
schools do provide merit aid and we
don't do that we're also committed
committed to meeting the full need of
all of our admitted students this has
been a more aggressive financial aid
policy than anyone would know up until
this year mit was spending more
financially dollars per enrolled student
than any of our peer institutions we
certainly were spending more financial
aid per endowment dollars than any of
our peer institutions so we have really
been out there ahead this policy has
been fantastic the the years the
freshman class that will come next year
18 percent of those students will be the
first in their families to go to college
the students here on campus 30% of our
students on campus come from families
with annual incomes of less than $75,000
a year this year we committed to meeting
the full tuition needs of these families
fully 17% of our students come from
families with incomes of less than
$45,000 MIT as you've heard me say
before is a place where the American
dream comes true
you all have told me your stories of how
getting financial aid allowed you to
come to MIT and coming to MIT allowed
you to change the world but we are
staying true to those policies and it is
clear from our admissions results that
MIT remains I would say continues to
grow as an attractive place for the
brilliant the most ambitious people in
the world to come the people who really
do want to change the world we have had
a great fundraising year thank you all
for for participating in the Alumni fund
we assited set a new record there we set
a new record and resource development
and what I can say about this is that
what we do at MIT clearly resonates with
alumni and with others I could talk
about some of these startling
achievements of our faculty but I'm
gonna let the faculty talk about them
themselves
well our three faculty will talk to you
about it the last thing I would say I'm
gonna reveal the the secret of the
senior gift which Beth very decorously
say that we'll wait for lunch some of
you aren't going to be at lunch but I
would say for me the most important
measure of our success is the seniors
haven't been given a chance to say thank
you my time at MIT
meant a great deal to me the senior gift
this year has blown away all previous
records the year I arrived four years
ago when I stood this podium I didn't
talk about the senior gift because the
participation that year was 27% and I
could not say that without hanging my
head in some embarrassment thinking -
only 27% of our students think that this
was a valuable experience for them
so Beth and I put our heads together and
I challenged Beth to challenge the
students to say you know please tell us
that this was important to you this
year's senior gift when I last checked
was 65 percent participation hurrah for
the class of 2008
and I would say hurrah for the Alumni
Association I am heartbroken that Beth
will be leaving us she has led the
Association in extraordinary ways she
was going on to a new challenge which I
have to say I can understand how RISD
calls on a spirit who has been motivated
by MIT how the spirit of RISD would
motivate her further let me stop there
and if I allow it left any time perhaps
we can get some questions and thank you
all very much for coming back to campus
and joining us protect day
well the index card system is working we
have a few really good questions for
president Hockfield the first is Susan
what has surprised you the most about
your job here at MIT so what surprised
me the most that's a great question
people ask it all the time so I should
have an answer ready answer I will tell
you quite frankly the thing that
surprised me the most you all know I was
at a pretty good school before I came to
MIT and I had a pretty good job at that
pretty good schools and other schools
that tried to persuade me that it would
be more exciting to go to their school
and lead them and I you know I said you
know I really don't think it's gonna be
more interesting to go to your lovely
school but when MIT came calling
obviously it was a a compelling I would
say an irresistible call to service to
come to MIT and I came here because I
knew that it's a great place it's the
best science and technology based
university in the world the thing that
surprised me most MIT is far better far
stronger far warmer far more interesting
than anyone on the outside knows this
place continues to take my breath away
every time I talk to faculty you'll
you'll have this experience this morning
I find myself in a future I had not yet
imagined at my previous very fine school
that happens from time to time but not
with the kind of dependable regularity
that happens to me here at MIT
and next question is what do you see as
the key challenges and the questioners
suggest that you propose your top five
that face MIT in coming years good this
mic great that I you you can keep the
podium I'll walk around with this in my
hand the top five challenges if I do the
top five challenges we won't have any
more questions so so let me pick a
couple the first is a challenge I
mentioned which is support for the
enterprise we're engaged in this is a
very serious challenge
I mentioned the problem about federal
research funding this is an important
challenge not just for MIT but for the
nation we really have to get our heads
around the fact that these are
investments they're not expenditures I
gave you some numbers about research in
heart disease that has really
transformed transformed saved lives
these are investments I could give you
the same kind of numbers for the battle
on AIDS which in the beginning of the
80s it looked like by the middle
eighties it looked like every hospital
bed everywhere in America was going to
have an AIDS patient in it we have
turned to AIDS from a death sentence to
a chronic manageable disease through
investments through investments the
return on the investments to come up
with a treatment for AIDS has been a
hundred and forty times so as a nation
we really have to you know get ourself
oriented so that impacts MIT and it
might teach commitment to helping build
life-changing technologies but it's also
true for education
no one could could have escaped hearing
about the battering that I would say
that higher ed has gotten at the hands
of Congress and now the media this year
this is ridiculous
the higher education system in America
is the best in the world we are the envy
of the world and for Congress and other
people to spend their time beating up
these well endowed institutions well
endowed what do we do with those dollars
we turn them into these discoveries we
turn them into the inventors and the
innovations of the future so this is a
very serious challenge for MIT and also
for the country on the positive side we
have a fabulous challenge which is
you know to address and this is the
challenge of problems that reach far
across departments and schools reach
between institutions reached between the
Academy and Industry and so a really
important challenge for us is building
the kinds of interconnections that allow
our spectacular faculty and students to
really get their hands around the
problems of today now this is a problem
I think MIT is positioned to address
better than just about any university in
the world and so I embrace this
challenge not in a very active way as do
our faculty and students great I think
we have time for one last question and I
actually it addresses a couple of
questions that that came through one is
MIT attracts elite young people for its
science and engineering program but the
need for engineers and scientists is
great
another question says is MIT doing
anything toward changing current
attitudes of the US public towards
science now I know that K through 12
education is one of your big concerns
and also I know I've been reading your
op-eds in the Boston Globe but maybe
this audience would like to hear a
little bit about those initiatives and
how you're trying to address these
concerns that are raised by these
questions yeah so this is something I
committed myself to the Institute to
when I started and I will share with you
a story when I first met with the search
committee um there was this period of
you know kind of getting to know you and
search committees always ask a question
and I'm guilty of the same thing when
I've been on a search committee you know
what should MIT do and I looked around
at this group who knew you know
infinitely more about MIT than I do I
say how would I know what MIT should do
plude you please tell me what MIT should
do but then I made an appeal I said
whether the next president is me or
anyone else it's very important that MIT
share the news of what we do far more
broadly and far more powerfully and I
have and kim has mentioned a couple of
the efforts to share the news about MIT
I hope you have noticed that you I hope
your you really are noticing that
mentions of MIT happen more frequently
in the newspapers and the media that you
read I did a piece on Charlie Rose
beginning of February to help get the
story out I had a series of op eds
the globe but it's not just me our
faculty are travelling around the world
our alumni sit all over the world and
are the information army it's very
important that what we do and how we do
at MIT is a story that gets out I talk
about MIT being a more powerful beacon
for inspiration around these issues of
Science and Technology science and
engineering and I talk about kind of you
know the visual piece of this which is
lighting the dome a year ago moving the
MIT Museum to the first floor so anyone
who travels up or down Massachusetts
Avenue can get a peek at the fabulous
innovations that are going on here
OpenCourseWare is another vehicle that
we're using to inspire the world or give
access to science and engineering that
people wouldn't normally have when we at
our event in November when we announced
our goal of having our 1800 courses
online we also celebrated the opening of
a new portal for OpenCourseWare it's
called highlights for high school one of
the things that we had discovered among
the years of users of OpenCourseWare was
that a lot of high school students and
high school teachers are using
OpenCourseWare any of you who have been
on the site know that it's not such an
easy site to navigate and so we imagined
we could create a portal that would make
it more accessible for these high school
students and teachers so we opened a
portal called highlights for high school
it's really a pie light pilot phase it's
it's going very well I mean any of you
who's interested in this kind of
outreach should go on the site it is
just a very exciting site and in true
MIT fashion what I imagined it would
look like is dwarfed by what it actually
does look like so this is one way of
getting the information out we are
working I've got a team of people
working on how to increase the
visibility for MIT and believe me it's
not about it being good for MIT although
I believe it will be good for MIT it's
about a stronger more powerful way for
MIT to serve the nation in the world so
this continues to be a work in progress
I would say you are the best measures of
whether this is happening so I hope in
another year or two years or five years
when you're back you will be able to say
with confidence sure enough I'm hearing
a lot more about MIT and the world and
more than that is that kids in the high
schools in my town my city are asking
about you know how can I go to MIT how
can I pursue science and engineering so
that I can help invent the future for
America in the world with that thank you
all for coming to tech day it is great
to have you back on campus share the
world about MIT where you come from
[Applause]
today and now while he gets his computer
set up and gets ready to go it's my
pleasure to introduce max tegmark max is
an associate professor in the physics
department here and his specialty is
something I have to read precision
cosmology and so I hope that in the next
25 minutes or so we'll gain an
understanding together of what that is
so Thank You max thank you welcome it's
a great pleasure to be here
and it's a great pleasure to get to work
on cosmology here at MIT because there
are just so many wonderful people to
work with we're extremely enthusiastic
about this subject
precision cosmology as you mentioned
that sounded kind of like a joke it's
not too long ago when people had been
arguing for ages about the factor of 10
in some measurement and that was a
factor of 10 in the exponent right and I
as I hope to share with you today that
has really changed and it's changed
because of tech which is the theme of
our day today and it's not just I hear
and feel excited about cosmology
even my emergence we deshji men on the
Nobel Committee have realized it's
exciting in the sight of the give a
noble prize to the field recently John
Mather in the george smoot and of course
where did he get his ph.d any guesses
and we'll come back to what they
discovered shortly but first what I
would like to do is completely turn off
these floods that lights here up in
front and get a really really nice and
dark and take you on a little journey to
remind ourselves of our place in space
let's turn the lights off completely
thank you so what's this very good the
Kresge Auditorium so let's go for a
little ride I promise we'll come back
so as we start zooming out we need to
make a slight change of equipment to be
able to go a little bit further and just
to set the scales here in our solar
system as you all know it takes light
about eight minutes to get from the
orbit of the earth from stone now to
Earth's orbit so we see the Sun not the
way it is right now but the way it was
eight minutes ago and nonetheless our
solar system is puny compared to the
distances to the nearby stars what
you're seeing here is not a computer
simulation but a real three-dimensional
map of the stars in our neighborhood
painstakingly built up by astronomers
across the world and the typical stars
you'll see here in Cambridge on a clear
night are hundreds of light-years away
which means that if someone out there is
looking at us they won't see us they
might see the Boston Tea Party and this
as well is where we casually call our
solar neighborhood in my field is just a
small part of this beautiful
agglomeration of hundreds of billions of
stars we know as our Milky Way galaxy we
live about here about a hundred thousand
light-years from side to side beautiful
pizza shape with a big bulge in the
middle and this familiar spiral
structure seen from the top now for me
it's quite remarkable to think that when
my grandma went on her first date
this was the universe a little part of
this galaxy
it wasn't until 1925 that the American
astronomer Edwin Hubble showed that the
that there were other galaxies and now
we're so spoiled there was just a few
clicks of my mouse we can zoom out until
our whole galaxy is just a little dot
and now all these other dots aren't
stars anymore there are other galaxies
with hundreds of millions of stars of
their own and if we pretend for a moment
that the speed of light is infinite so I
can drive as fast as I want then let's
take a little ride
and check out our intergalactic
neighborhood
now we're hundreds of millions of
light-years away so if you took a peek
back from here you wouldn't see that
Boston Tea Party you might see dinosaurs
roaming around here and there are two
things that really jump out at you again
first of all this is not a computer
simulation this is a real
three-dimensional map of our
neighborhood okay the two things that
jump out of you are first galaxies are
kind of like MIT alumni and like to hang
out with others in groups clusters super
clusters and you see these giant
filamentary structures here basically
because gravity is an attractive force
and clump stuff together
and moreover wherever you see lots of
galaxies we've since learned that there
is also much more dark matter
so we effectively seeing a dark matter
map you're illuminated by galaxies much
like when you're flying over Boston by
night you only see the city lights which
make up a small fraction of all the
stuff but from the contours you can
learn a lot more about what's really
there the second thing which jumps out
at me when I look at this is that by now
it's getting a little bit boring it's
kind of been there done that more the
same and we have a fancy geek word for
that we call it universes we say that
the universe is homogeneous and
isotropic on large scales which in plain
english just means that on average our
universe seems to be it's kind of the
same everywhere it's only when you zoom
out still more that you see that in fact
it's a cube
this is of course just a reiteration of
Susan Hockfield to remark that we have
plenty more to do in science in this
case we want to map farther let's see go
beyond where a funding ran out here so
let me now share with you a a little bit
of about a project that I have spent a
lot of time working on was called with
them with my colleagues on it's called a
Sloan Digital Sky Survey and it's the
most ambitious project to date to map
our universe in two and three dimensions
and let's turn off these spotlights
again
you can keep it nice and light there in
the back so you don't get too
comfortable in your seats but this is
this is perfect now what I want to do
here is just show you our data you
recognize the Big Dipper here and I'm
gonna just zoom in in this old sky map
on a part right below the tail of the
Big Dipper
these are just photos okay and I can
zoom in like this anywhere in the sky I
encourage you to when you get back home
to go to Google Sky and fly around
because they have our Sloan Digital Sky
Survey data in there already
just to give you this sort of sort of
sense of what 10 to the power 8 objects
really involved it's a huge amount of
information and then what we do with
this is we have a cup of course I can't
give a grad student to 10 to the 8
objects and tell them to come back when
they've looked at them all so you feed
them to your computer and the computer
selects out the most interesting ones
and anyone goes back and measures
distances to them and then one can go
and build up these kind of
three-dimensional sky maps that we flew
around a minute ago and let's start
start again at the Milky Way now and and
start heading out you can hear a
narration here by my colleague Josh
Freeman
there's light from each galaxy in more
detail using an instrument called a
spectrograph we are now tens of millions
of light-years from Earth galaxies come
in a variety of shapes sizes and colors
from typical blue spiral galaxies like
our own Milky Way to giant red
elliptical or oval-shaped galaxies now
hundreds of millions of light years from
Earth we see that galaxies collect
together in groups ranging from a few
galaxies to great clusters containing
many hundreds of galaxies to large
web-like structures stretching across
hundreds of millions of light-years the
survey is being carried out in thin
slices across the sky like pieces of a
watermelon when completed these slices
will merge together to form a
three-dimensional map of the universe
cosmologists believe that these
large-scale structures evolved from
small ripples in the fabric of space
generated a tiny fraction of a second
after the Big Bang about 14 billion
years ago
beyond the Sloan survey we reached the
cosmic microwave background radiation as
mapped by NASA's W map satellite this
radiation gives us a picture of the
universe when it was only 400,000 years
old
the colored patches show directions on
the sky where the temperature is
slightly hotter and cooler than average
by analyzing and comparing the data from
these different kinds of surveys
cosmologists are closing in on a
consistent picture of how the universe
evolved from its earliest moments to the
present day now wait a minute what was
just when it all seemed like what we
were doing was mapping space we bump
into this weird greenish sphere what's
that all about and you heard my
colleague Josh Freeman calling it the
cosmic no microwave background which is
what George smoothed in John Mather
awarded the Nobel Prize for taking
pictures of so
is this why does it look like we're
surrounded by a giant sphere we clearly
need to get to the bottom of that and to
understand it we must understand not
only our place in space but also our
place in time of course since it takes
time for light to travel the farther
away we look the farther into the past
we see what you're looking at here is
four raise your hand if you would
classify yourself as a photography buff
all right I'm touched to see so many
kindred souls here this it's an
extremely cool photo imagine being able
to take an exposure four-month exposure
with your camera with lens which has a
two and a half meter opening okay okay
then have your telescope in space so
there's always pointing towards the same
part of it's them then then these front
spots again otherwise it'll miss the big
Alex okay and moreover because it's such
an amazing photo you can get an amazing
detail the entire part of the sky you're
seeing here is so small but if you hold
up your hand like this and imagine
you're holding a pin in it from here to
here corresponds to the width of your
pan head okay the width of a needle it's
called and was taken with the Hubble
Space Telescope and you see a lot of
things here which happened twelve
thirteen billion years ago so looking
back from there you wouldn't even see
earth which only came on the scene
four-and-a-half billion years ago and
from looking at different distances away
from us we've been able to put together
a very quantitative picture of what our
universe looked like at different times
of the past I'm summarizing it all on
this slide here we know that everything
that we can see everything in the
spherical region from which light has a
time to get here so far it was about
fourteen billion years ago extremely hot
and dense we call this our Big Bang and
since then two basic processes have been
taking place all the stuff has been
flying apart
expanding which have causes it of course
from to become less dense and also less
hot and there's a second process as well
it's transformed from being very smooth
much like the air in this room okay
where the density varies from place to
place only at the part a part in 10 to
minus 5 because I'm talking because of
the sound waves if I'm but this loud it
was very similar in our cosmic past and
then gravity amplified this and
transition the smooth gas distribution
there's a smooth hydrogen gas into
clumpy and interesting hydrogen which
eventually turn into the galaxies the
planets and the an MIT and all the other
good stuff we have today ok and you can
see that illustrate is schematically
here again by looking into the past with
various techniques we can map out more
recent past various galaxies see back to
a time before there were any galaxies
and thereby figuring out when galaxies
started to form and then when we look
still further back we see this funky
Cosmic Microwave Background which we
need to explain and understand and
before that my colleague Alan Guth here
at MIT came up with the most popular
explanation for what happened it called
inflation the theory is that if you just
have a very tiny region of space
containing a substance which won't
dilute very much when it stretches out
and that tiny region of space will
rapidly double and double and double its
size and be and expand and become larger
than everything we can see now there are
many different techniques which have
burst on the scene combining various
technologies to let us peer into the
past and get quantitative about this so
30 years ago cosmology was largely
viewed as somewhere out there between
philosophy and metaphysics you could
speculate over a bunch of beers about
what happened and then you can go home
because there wasn't a whole lot else to
do where's now we're treated to this
wonderful data given to us by space
technology improvements detector
technology and computer technology to
make sense of it all I want to give you
a little we've talked a lot already
about galaxies surveys
by flying around in our universe let me
explain now what this microwave
background is so when we look into the
past
we're looking through all this black
stuff in which we as kids call empty
space but it's not empty it's all full
of hydrogen and when you look farther
back
this was denser and denser hotter and
hotter if you just heat up a bunch of
hydrogen eventually it gets so hot that
it turns into a plasma and the plasma is
opaque just like that wall there so it
looks to us like we're staring into an
opaque plasma screen over on that side
but of course it's gonna be the same
whatever direction we look so it's gonna
appear to us like we're inside of plasma
sphere that doesn't mean we're in the
center somehow are of everything it's
more like when you're walking around in
the fog and you can only see you 100
yards in each direction you're gonna be
in the center of your own fog sphere
right but so is everybody else so don't
get hubris from this now fortunately
technology that has given us the great
maps of this plasma sphere you can just
photograph it you need to do you have a
microwave camera and the first to see
these patterns were the Nobel laureates
I mentioned these better pictures were
taken by NASA's Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe satellite which is
revolutionize the field since we talked
about money it's all I would share with
you what this cost this amazing
experiment which is revolutionize their
field cost 40 cents per American there's
a good investment if I've ever seen one
now let me summarize the storyline of
how we got here in slightly more visual
terms so I talked about two processes
expansion and clustering this is a
supercomputer simulation performed by
Ben Moore in his group where you see
both the expansion and the clustering
and all he's done is he's put the laws
of gravity into his computer and the
rather uniform stuff and flying apart
and you see eventually how you start
getting very complicated and intricate
clustering patterns here
my eyes get mostly drawn to the
expansion part here at the expense of
the clustering so let me show you
another version of this where the
expansion is just artificially taken out
so you can see how gravity has the power
to transform something rather uniform
and boring there's something really
clumpy and interesting this is a few
hundred million light years from
scientist side and you'll recognize very
similar patterns here predicted by pure
theory in your computer to the galaxies
distribution that we flew through right
in fact the individual blobs that we're
seeing here are the scale of typical
galaxies so you can imagine that within
each of them you might evolve a galaxy
perhaps not unlike our own let's zoom in
now on one individual matter clump like
this and take a look at another
supercomputer simulation this one has
been done by a my colleague Mathia
Steinmetz in Potsdam Germany we're
staying here on the left side a top view
of the same thing that we're seeing in a
side view on the right side here he's
we've put in he's put in a little bit
more physics in addition to gravity also
the basic jazz physics that's been very
well proven and tested in the lab so no
far-fetched assumptions at all and you
start making stars and the stars formed
with the speed clumps and you see the
bottom line of galaxy formation is it's
not like first our galaxy wasn't there
and then it formed and then it's sat
there rather it's been a very messy
process of formation much like a giant
series of traffic accidents on the
freeway where every time you think
you're done more stuff crashes in from
the side in fact if you look around
yourself in the sky and the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey we're making you will
see that right now our Milky Way galaxy
is busy gobbling up its innocent
bystander the Sagittarius dwarf galaxy I
actually don't know how innocent it is
but that's what's going on
and by now you see it's already
beginning to look quite a bit like a
spiral galaxy from the top and you see
the beginning - it was a formation or
rather pizza shape disk here all the red
stuff is dark matter dark matter is red
at least in your computer where you can
pick a color that you can see and
although this is very much work in
progress in many details remain to be
ironed out it's very encouraging that
one can get such a good qualitative
agreement between theory and observation
here's another supercomputer simulation
done by Mike by Tom Abel and his team
where they have used adaptive mesh
refinement to keep zooming in on smaller
and smaller patches and get all the way
from the scale of a galaxy to this much
smaller scale of a solar system and what
happens is you have a spinning gas cloud
contracting under its gravity again as
it dissipates a radiates away its energy
cells into it a pizza shape pancake
because angular momentum is conserved
that can't collapse into a point and
eventually it gets so dense in the core
that the hydrogen ignites nuclear fusion
and the star is born and all the while
gas in the outer parts of these disks
this disk is clumped into planets which
become revealed once the nascent star
blows away their remaining in there of
this gas disc and because although I am
the angular momentum came from this gas
cloud it's no surprise that in our solar
system all the planets are orbiting
around the Sun in the same sense which
is also the same sense that the Sun is
spinning in the same sense as most of
the planets are spinning and just to
come back to home again and and put this
in perspective I want to remind you that
even our planet is constantly evolving
when I first heard about plate tectonics
I thought that 200 million years was
just an awful long time but think about
it this is less than a few percent of
the age of our universe alright so this
is a very very brief summary of how our
how MIT got here
and since we actually managed to cover
14 billion years in just 20 minutes
let's take you a little quick peek at
our future as well because we don't have
to press stop when the computer gets to
the present time here we see our solar
system orbiting around in red here
orbiting around the center of our Milky
Way galaxy which is done about 15 times
so far and in the future
here are some trouble coming this isn't
the Andromeda galaxy our nearest big
neighbor hold on to your hats because
although there's a lot of other stuff
pulling in the neighborhood here about
three and half billion years from now
whammo it's not as bad as it looks cuz
[Laughter]
because most of the stars actually miss
each other but we are in a slightly more
precarious orbit now closer to the
monster black hole in the middle of our
galaxy here comes the biggest corporate
merger you'll ever see and a Milky Way
and Andromeda merges into what I think
they're gonna call milk Amida but we'll
see what they decide and our solar
system is now in a very disturbing orbit
here so maybe we'll figure out some some
good way of moving to a slightly better
place at that time now this is a good
story did I but why should you believe a
word of it short answer again is data
this is tech day so I I'm not gonna feel
guilty about stressing importance of
data and technology and measurement over
and over again and it's really been
remarkable science magazine hailed as
the number one breakthrough of the year
quite recently this fact that because of
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey and this
NASA microwave satellite and so on we
could now really start believing rather
than ridiculing as many of these
cosmological predictions it's the
measurements which have transformed this
just like measurements transformed other
things which people didn't used to
believe in into revealed science and
we've talked now about the spectacular
measurement just photographs of this
plasma sphere which where will these hot
the different colors correspond to
slinky slight differences in how dense
it is in different parts of the baby
universe and just to put this in
perspective on this scale again of our
observable universe which is also
basically the region of space from which
light time to get here so far which is
what we usually just call our universe
ok so if you want to print out a t-shirt
with the picture of the universe this
would be the iconic image you would use
on the same scale all we've mapped so
far in three dimensions is this puny
stuff here in the middle let me zoom in
on this here and you'll see the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey again with all these
galaxies
different colors corresponding the
different types so we have a long way to
go but already with these rather modest
three-dimensional maps we can do a lot
of great physics because we can take
these measured three-dimensional maps
and compare them with computer simulated
maps and the good news is we can get
them to agree we can get the statistical
properties of how stuff is clump stir to
match beautifully but it only agrees if
you put in very specific values for like
how much atoms there is per unit volume
and various other things so one can turn
these pictures from just being fun
things to look at to being extremely
useful probes of numbers and numbers is
of course what we're all about here so
we call our numbers cosmological
parameters you've come across many of
them already
one set of numbers just tells you what
the universe is made up of on average
and we were quite taken to realize as a
community that only 4% of the stuff is
atoms or what do we matter that there is
about five times more of this invisible
stuff we call dark matter and then still
three times more called dark energy to
show you a slightly more geeky plot let
me take this number of atoms plus the
dark matter and plot it on this axis
versus the amount of dark energy here
because this inflation theory of Alan
Guth which sounded very frivolous the
way I've first introduced it makes some
very quantitative predictions one of
them is that this number plus this
number should equal one in these units
which means then that the truth in this
plane should lie somewhere on this
diagonal line yeah right well does it
for many years we couldn't measure now
we can so Alan Guth theory is testable
this NASA satellite came in at first and
killed off all of the Reds area of this
parameter plane at 95% confidence so
it's beginning to look good for the
prediction of the line here then the
data from the satellite got better but
we still couldn't really be sure if we
were here or here when we put in our
Sloan Digital Sky Survey work we got
this ruled out too
and we can now measure that this sum of
the two numbers which was predicted to
be won by Alan Guth inflation theory
we've measured it to be one point zero
zero three plus minus one percent so a
beautiful agreement and we've gone from
arguing about a factor 10 on the
exponent to a one percent measurement
and there are many other numbers I
promise to not show you too many more
otherwise I'll be chastised afterwards
if you own we can put good numbers to
the different stages in the evolution of
our universe if you're only gonna
remember a single number when you go
back home to tell your friends about I
recommend that be this one current age
of our universe since years it's just
remarkable even when I was a postdoc we
were arguing about whether our universe
is ten billion years old or 20 billion
years old now we arguing about whether
it's 13.7 billion or 13.8 billion that's
how fast things have changed okay I
promise to not just spend their whole
time dousing your numbers so let's shift
gears and talk about something a little
bit more philosophical because num we do
don't get numbers alone out of cosmology
you also get a much greater sense of
where we are in the grand scheme of
things all right so let me pose this
question is there more that exists then
we can see I already mentioned how when
my grandma was young they had no idea
how much stuff was really out there so I
made this little plot showing how much
we knew existed as a function of year
and it's really been quite remarkable on
this crazy log scale here right from
when people first realized the size of
the earth I was in Egypt yesterday and
it was amazing to see Eratosthenes place
of work in Alexandria and so on and see
how blown away they must have been by by
this and and then every time we thought
it wasn't gonna get any bigger it did
and just in the last 100 years we've
realized that it doesn't stop at the
galaxy our galaxy or other galaxies in
fact there's absolutely no reason to
think that space
abruptly here it's like if you're
walking around in the fog why should you
think there's no more space just beyond
your visit where you can see alan guth
theory of inflation doesn't just predict
that space is big it actually predicts
that it's infinite it would be kind of
odd if there was a sign saying space
ends here you don't mind the gap but
take my word for it
there are other ways in which you can
have envision the space actually not
thing infinitely big but but this
inflation theory predicts infinite space
ok so suppose it's right then you have
an infinite space and we are calling
using the phrase our universe to
describe a region from which light can
get here in 14 billion years then
they're instantly mini other such
regions right but some people like to
call parallel universes this inflation
theory also predicts that there's going
to be stuff there's gonna be stars and
all those other regions - it's just that
the atom is start out in slightly
different places so slightly different
things happen you can calculate but if
we go about a googolplex meters in that
direction you will come to another
universe which is identical to ours and
be long before you come there you'll
find some other ones which are very
similar looking it'll be a commencement
going on a tab in the shreddy auditorium
and so on so pretty dizzying thoughts
it's predicted by this theory which of
course brings in the the philosophy
Buster you have to ask yourself our
theories which predict the existence of
unobservable things untestable and
therefore not science for me if it's not
testable if not science ok nonetheless
I feel that inflation is testable
because for a theory to be what we're
testing here our mathematical equations
right that's what these theories
ultimately are and for it to be testable
we don't have to be able to test all
their predictions we have to be able to
produce to test only at least one right
then it already has it stands a chance
of being falsified so let me give you an
example
Einstein's theory of gravity predicts
exactly what happens inside of a black
hole if you should fall in don't
recommend trying
but at least it can rest assure that you
can get a good forecast for what should
happen all right
that's untestable because it can't come
back out and publish your findings but
we nonetheless take this prediction very
seriously because the theory has a nice
time it makes all these other
predictions for why your GPS navigator
works the way it works and so on and so
forth right so the analogy is inflation
predicts pace is infinite if that's
right or any other theory that makes an
infant's basis right then you're stuck
with much vaster reality then then we
can observe if you're agra furball agra
phobic i guess that's the problem but I
think if you're claustrophobic it's
great besides our job as scientists of
course isn't to tell the universe how he
wanted to be but to figure out how it is
so let me wrap up by looking a bit
forward here so when I was a grad
student and a postdoc we talked a lot
about how great it was going to be when
we would have these precision
measurements that we've flown through
and and marveled at and how he would be
able to use them to measure these
numbers these cosmological parameters
well now we've accomplished quite a bit
of out of that and measured some of them
even to a percent level accuracy so
what's next to me the most exciting part
lies ahead which is using these
measurements to learn something about
the fundamental nature of reality the
fundamental physics that lies behind
this and as always in science when we
discover something new where the answer
comes a host of great new questions
we've measured how much dark matter
there is but hey what is it there are
very good we might even find out this
year and I can tell you why if you're
asking about it in the question period
what we've measured how much dark energy
there is what's that
we've measured that there were these
fluctuations at the 10 to minus 5 level
in the early universe which seat where
the Seas that created all the galaxies
you know where do they come from and why
do all these numbers have the valleys
they do not other values there are a lot
of very deep questions here and for all
of these three questions here what's the
nature of dark matter dark energy and
the early universe the basic measurement
you want to do to answer them is you
want to map our universe and I don't
mean this map a little piece of it
anymore I mean map everything we can map
I've mentioned how there were lots of
great techniques out there which have
already mapped various parts of it right
so let me just close by telling you
about what I think might be the next big
thing in cosmology which can again blow
away the precision we've achieved so far
this is something which I personally am
spending a lot of time on now with my
group here at MIT and it's called
neutral hydrogen tomography or 21
centimeter tomography which sounds very
geeky and I'll explain shortly what it
is the goal is to map all of this okay
everything in this sphere and look how
little we've done all the galaxies we've
ever seen are in this tiny fraction of
the volume near the middle and these
baby pictures the microwave background
which gave that Nobel Prize they all
came from a thin spherical shell as
thick as this figure this black line
here so again a very small fraction of
the volume right now the basic idea
behind this technique is all of us fear
is full of hydrogen hydrogen gas can
give off electromagnetic radiation of a
wavelength of 21 centimeters but if it
gives it off in the distant past when
space was much smaller then these waves
will be stretched out and reach earth at
a longer wavelength so instead of
getting here at them they might get here
with wavelengths that one meter or two
meters can it was just defense the bees
right on the around the FM band you know
100 megahertz 200 megahertz and so on so
you don't need any fancy detectors for
that it's just cheap radio basically and
with it weather colleague and my mother
has earlier a guy recently proposed what
we were actually just last week a
telescope we call a fast for you
transform telescope which you can think
of basically as a giant sea of really
really cheap radio antennas hooked up
with with into a computer what's the
point of that well to be able to map all
the hydrogen in our universe obviously
you need really really good sensitivity
to get really really low noise right and
it's pretty obvious that the bigger your
telescope is the lower your noise is
going to be but big isn't big is
expensive for an ordinary telescope if
you imagine taking a radio dish like
this and building it a kilometer wide
and then being able to have any motors
that can point it without it falling
over you know who's a mechanical
engineer that sounds pretty expensive
doesn't it
yeah and another technique it's but this
has been very successful is to take a
lot of radio antennas and instead
connect them to a computer and that way
try to reconstruct the map but for that
the cost goes like the area squared it's
just really expensive for this idea it's
the cost scaled only as area and it I'm
gonna since this is tech day I'm
unabashedly gonna talk about slightly
nerdy tech stuff here at the ray and use
the word for you transform a few times
so I apologize in advance but I want to
give you a flavor for how again what's
really driving cosmology isn't just big
philosophical questions but it's really
technology a telescope it's basically a
four e transformer and if you don't know
what a four a transformer is expect
which I'm not least you're certainly not
required to in plain English this just
means that you have this electric field
everywhere in space and you simply want
to decompose it into waves you want to
know how much waves do you have of
different wavelengths coming from
different directions the directions from
which the waves come and the sky is what
exactly what gives you the map right and
the length of the waves tells you how
much those waves have been stretched out
since they were 21 centimeters long and
therefore how far away the radiation
came from giving you the full
three-dimensional map of our universe
they were trying to make
and the basic idea is instead of
building fancy expensive equipment you
just place an order for a million of a
cheapest TV antennas from China or
whatever and then you and because of
Moore's law you can now do something
which was previously impossible you can
take the electric field even at
frequencies up to like a gigahertz and
just immediately digitize it your cell
phones do that for like $3 for the
equipment it would because you know 1
gigahertz is a pretty slow computer
today and then you can do all the math
that the telescope you should do by
analog means in software which is I
think the way to all telescopes pretty
much you're going to work eventually in
the future and just to put it all
together for you here if you're trying
to measure anything in science the
accuracy with which you can do it
basically goes like 1 over the square
root of the number of numbers that you
have right and this is roughly how many
independent numbers were measured by
different cosmological experiments in
the past early galaxies surveys this
Nobel Prize experiment nailed a few
hundred this fantastic NASA satellite
bit over a million and yet you see this
is a linear scale and time thick NASA
satellite bit over a million and yet you
see this is a linear scale and time
versus a log scale and how much
information you have this is like your
Moore's law again where every few years
you double how well you can do and well
this fast Fourier transform telescope is
as much better it and then the current
state of the art as the current state of
the art is from the early days and if
you could go map even modestly just just
the not the whole observable universe
but just the band I've shaded here and
dark blue which turns out to be the
easiest place to start this number has
now been measured to one percent
accuracy for instance we could measure
it to almost to a 50th of a percent
accuracy which would be very interesting
for testing these theories you can also
mention measure pretty much all other
numbers that one cares about with great
precision
so to conclude I've tried to give you a
little bit of a flavor for why I'm so
excited to get to be at MIT and work on
cosmology I've tried to give you a
flavor for how this field has really
transformed from being very
philosophical to be very data-driven and
quantitative and in the process we've
not only managed to map our place in
space and time
quite exquisitely but also been able to
connect more and more with fundamental
questions in physics and last but not
least yes since this is tech day and I
have tried to show you that as much fun
as this has been the most exciting stuff
in cosmology I think lies ahead so the
universe is gonna be a very happy place
to do cuts for cosmology thank you thank
you very much
all right well thanks so much and we did
actually get a few questions and I
should say I I was in the architecture
planning department when I was here so
this is way beyond my Ken but if you
were understanding quite everything
about the universe nobody else does
either
so one question is if the microwave
background originated in the Big Bang
and if light travels faster than matter
how come the microwave background is
still here and is not far beyond us what
am i answer that question first then
okay so the answer the first question
about why there's still stuff here if it
were like would have gone away at the
speed of light is you shouldn't think of
the Big Bang is an explosion which
happened right here and we humans have
historically always liked to try to put
ourselves in the center of everything
right going all the way back to Jura
centric cosmology rather what we call
the Big Bang is an event in time not at
a particular place everything we see was
once extremely hot and dense so wherever
you were 13.7 billion years ago it was
extremely hot okay so the Micra
background radiation we're seeing now
was somewhere else in the past and the
stuff which was here then is over there
now and
[Music]
and this then the MIT did you want to
read the next question or okay if the
microwave background originated if the
Big Bang was so dense how come it wasn't
the black hole it's an excellent
question in a sense it was a bit like a
black hole backwards it's just known as
a white hole if you just if you just
have this much stuff sitting there and
that dance it would very quickly
collapse in on itself and that would
that would put a very untimely end to
this commencement planning okay no but
it was flying apart extremely fast and
became less and less and less dense and
was flying apart so fast that for
billions of years
just that momentum of the motion was
able to overpower the desire for gravity
to crunch it all together again and we
still don't know for sure how it's all
gonna end we used to think that I was
taught for example in grad school that
either it was gonna expand forever and
the momentum would win or if there was a
bit less stuff and less gravitational
pull it would all come crashing back on
itself in the Big Crunch and then we
managed to measure accurately how much
stuff there was and it seemed like it
was not enough stuff for a Big Crunch so
the article started to peer in the
popular press saying it's gonna expand
forever and we're gonna end in a Big
Chill the world will end not with a bang
but a whimper but then this dark energy
came on the scene which has this bizarre
property that it's it doesn't dilute so
now if it's 75% of his stuff is dark
energy our stuff will dilute too soon
the dark energy will be 95% 99% and so
when in our future is figuring out our
future now is actually completely
equivalent to understanding what this
dark energy is which is why we want to
know what it is so if you want to go
home and tell your friends our world is
gonna end there have three options you
can give them on the menu depending on
what the dark energy is Big Crunch Big
Chill or a big rip where the dark energy
makes things expand faster and faster so
eventually everything gets torn apart
all right did you just answer these
questions or are these somewhat
different from like why can we perhaps
find out the nature of dark matter okay
that's a great one for dark matter I
think we have very very we live in a
very very exciting time in terms of them
making progress on it I would say
they're actually four routes to figuring
out what it is dark matter is kind of
it's it's stuff we know it's there
because it's gravitating so if first of
all if we just figure out more
accurately how it's pulling and stuff we
can learn more about it moreover though
it's quite likely that it's some kind of
particle that just is very arrogant and
doesn't want to have a whole lot to do
with it with us we already know there
are such particles called neutrinos
which when they hit my hand will just
just go through on the other side and
then it'll go through earth and go out
on the other side most of the time but
some people including my MIT colleagues
Peter Fisher Kelly Figueroa and Jocelyn
Monroe or building amazing experiments
to try to actually catch these particles
once in a blue moon when they fly
through MIT or some lab and there's been
such a remarkable progress that I
wouldn't be surprised if you'll read a
big splash about this in the New York
Times in the not-too-distant future
another thing you can try to do is make
dark matter particles we know we can
make new kinds of particles out of old
ones by smashing them together real hard
and everything energy we arrange itself
in new forms and this summer is one of
the most exciting events ever in the
history of physics the biggest machine
ever built through physics will switch
on in Geneva the Large Hadron Collider
which crashes particles together so hard
that you might actually have some dark
matter particles coming out which would
really revolutionize our understanding
of what this stuff is and there were
also some ways of indirectly learning
more about what dark matter is by
looking at very extreme locations out
there in space so so I'm quite
optimistic about the dark
mystery which has been kicking around
since 1930s actually being resolved to
alright here's a hopefully simple one
someone asks how do we get our hands on
a copy of deep space explorer 1.0 type
it into Google great stuff okay someone
else is wondering whether there are
current alternatives to the inflation
theory and are there plausible
alternatives in your opinion mm-hmm
that's a great great question
so what's just that what's happened
historically here in cosmology is that
there's always been a frontier of our
ignorance right and we've gradually
pushed it farther out in spacings
particularly farther back in time Newton
was able to figure out beautifully how
things move around in the solar system
but he had no clue why our solar system
was here in the first place right I
showed you it's computer simulation of
how you can actually make your plant and
solar system out of a gas cloud but then
you know when I told that bedtime story
to my my six-year-old son he said where
the gas cloud come from then right and
now then I showed you movies here of how
if you just if you start with a bunch of
hot gas flying apart you can actually
make galaxies gas cloud and so on but
what happened before that I think we
have really great confidence in what
happened since our universe was 400
thousand years old because that's how
far back we can just see and look
alright we also have very great
confidence in what happened since the
first second because when our universe
was a second old it was as bad as hot as
the core of the Sun and we know what
hydrogen does when it's as hot as the
core of the Sun it does the same thing
as it doesn't a son does fusion in terms
of the helium except of course it wasn't
that hot for very long you can calculate
that it only made 24% helium all right
you go out and look how much helium
there is in space 24 percent it's
remarkable and the what happened before
that that's really the current front
here
the inflation theory of Alan Guth and
his colleagues is in my opinion
definitely the front-runner theory
because it's passed a lot of
observational tests and you need to
assume very little there are many other
theories beaten that one that's getting
a lot of attention in the popular press
is a so-called Parekh universe with
colliding brains in the science
community I only know of three people
who believe in it and I won't name them
but I'm but this is still very much a
frontier our ignorance and we do not
know and I think it's extremely exciting
to ask what we can do with new
technologies to push that Frontiero
ignorance into the realm of what we can
see now you can't see through this
plasma because it's all page but why
should that stop you you know if you go
to the doctor and you want to know
what's going on with your kidney and
your doctor says sorry your opaque to my
electric romantic radiation I can't see
you'll ask for an x-ray all right and we
know that neutrinos can go right through
this so we can use them as a probe of
what happened before and the best probe
we have is is ripples in the fabric of
space-time itself known as gravitational
waves and there's this amazing
experiment to try to detect these
ripples in the fabric of space-time here
led by the LIGO experiment here at MIT
by this amazing group and if one can
measure gravitational waves of
wavelength comparable to the size of our
universe which you can also use with it
turns do it turns out by using this map
itself as a detector
I'm not gonna get into the details then
you were actually seeing we'd actually
be seeing stuff just like an x-ray in
the doctor's office which told you what
happened when the universe was way
younger when it was maybe 10 to the
power minus 34 seconds old and that
would really clinch what happened early
on and this is not some kind of
futuristic year 3000 technology this is
something that we have a technology and
principle to go look for today
and if there's appropriate funding and
for it I think well my people to do it
in the time scale of a decade or so so
very very exciting in my opinion I think
we have time for one more question and
there was well there's of course this
one but how about this one with your
focus on understanding space in the
development of the universe do you find
any evidence of life beyond humans on
earth great metaphysics what a great
question that there don't wouldn't and
we all wonder the this is another field
where which has been completely
revolutionized I'd a tech day say a
decade ago the total number of solar
systems known to exist was one and now
almost every week right you read in the
new year in the newspaper about new
planets discovered around other stars
and I'm also very excited to be here at
MIT where much of this pioneering work
is actually being carried out so far we
haven't found any planets which have
life on them if you ask me to guess I
think I'll make two predictions I think
first of all I don't think there is life
capable of space travel or a radio
transmission particularly close to us
because if they were why haven't they
shown up long and go no there are many
other planets which are just as
habitable as Earth that were formed
three billion years earlier so if you
let an institution like MIT operate for
three billion years surely it'll figure
out a way of going out and taking over
and opening it up opening up and up
other universities throughout the galaxy
right on the other hand my second
prediction is I think we're gonna
there's gonna be a real revolution in
our understanding of this in the next
five ten fifteen years because
even though there's life yeah
because even though we don't have
telescopes that are good enough to zoom
in on one of these planets and get
Landsat kind of images what you can do
is you can look at a planet you can find
ones which are in a put it in orbit so
that they sometimes get between you and
their parent star which means that when
they're eclipsing their store light from
the star will shine through the
atmosphere of the planet on the way to
earth and then you can look at this
spectrum of absorption lines in the
light and see if there's oxygen in that
atmosphere or other molecules which are
likely to have been created by some sort
of a perform life I don't think it's at
all unlikely that there are lower forms
of life maybe even cows and other there
many other forms of life which are
really interesting that just don't have
radios and I'm very much looking forward
to seeing what's going to come out from
this brand-new field and then in the
near future
thank you again
thank you so much
[Applause]
you
good morning everyone it's a real
pleasure to be here with you I look
forward to our time together so my
learning objectives for this discussion
err first to familiarize you with human
spaceflight
some of our research around MIT and
really to share my passion for human
exploration and aerospace biomedical
engineering with you like to demonstrate
my philosophy of teaching and research
it's love act discover and innovate I
think these are essential ingredients
for our research and learning activities
at MIT I'll take you on a journey not as
far out is into the universe as Max I'll
bring us a little bit closer to home
will start on Earth we'll make it to the
moon in Mars and then we'll probably
come full circle and come back to earth
again a bit of personal exploration and
finally I'll end by celebrating this and
posing some questions to you about
innovation and creativity and then
teaching at MIT so just to start a
little bit of the work we look at from
an engineering perspective but we're
very interested in how humans move and
how humans perform you just a simulation
there
biomechanical simulation it's a physics
based model it's a real simulation of
someone walking across the ground and we
also do work with robots human and
robots that ties into the next speaker
as well you'll hear professor Cynthia
Brazil so we're interested in capturing
human emotion and then using robots in
my sense as kind of surrogate astronauts
can we perform the same motions can we
control them can we make their work
easier to perform in very extreme
environments I also want to highlight
some student projects as I go so looking
at design especially designed here on
earth I wanted to show you some some
work with a collaborator for paraplegic
athletes so to wake us up a little bit
after the break I do have music on this
one the collaboration with keep Oakland
is from the Rhode Island School of
Design so could we design and build a
cycle for a paraplegic racers that would
be the world's fastest we did
aerodynamic testing
and the testing with paraplegic athletes
here at MIT we believe this is the
world's most aerodynamic cycle as you
can see it's controlled completely with
the upper body so if you have use of
your arms then you can power this cycle
you can steer the cycle and by moving
your body you can do some pretty nice
solemn moves as well so it was a really
great project to get together those
engineering students at MIT with some of
the design students at other
universities and really come up with
this prototype as I said it's actually
the the world's fastest at this point
but is still not legal for the Boston
Marathon but we did have we did have the
winner and the third place both a female
and males on this cycle to get the data
on them so that's just a kind of a
celebration of design like to move along
and I was earlie inspired in my MIT
career with with work of other
colleagues I'm showing you some
simulations here from what was then the
MIT leg lab so we're pretty fascinated
by how humans move has you know nature
can nature teach us everything we really
need to know and animals so there are
some wonderful simulations that mark
raybert and his folks had done anything
from kangaroos too ostriches and then
the real mix is okay let's see if we can
put these humans and robots together now
watch this biped robot because this is
pretty fantastic it's gonna perform nice
little motion for you here get ready
whoa supposed to clap there that's
pretty tough to do that's tough to do
this is not just an animation this is a
real physics based simulation so that
has all the equations of motion embedded
in it and then just to take you a little
bit beyond Earth well that's where I
spend most of my time and passion and
definitely wouldn't try wouldn't
recommend trying this at home but let's
see if we can get astronaut dr. Rhea
Seddon there so what have we really had
precision control about all degrees of
freedom we study this we try to employ
it in so much these smiling that is a
happy astronaut
I take you to the microgravity
environment of space stations then you
see here this astronaut Jerry Linenger
now again we're more like floating we're
doing horizontal motion we have some
smart sensors here this is our design
for the smart sensors you can carry the
electronics in the palm of your hand and
we've flown these on the shuttle as well
as a Russian Mir station and they're
targeted for the international space
station as well so we're pretty
fascinated with with motion and movement
and control and I'd like to tell you a
little bit more about that this is a
collaboration with Professor Hugh hare
here and our graduate student on Kimball
IU who performed that work so again
we're modeling the muscles when you're
firing your muscles on and off then we
came up with an active ankle-foot
orthosis you see here in the video on
the right this is a patient after stroke
he has what's known as dropped foot his
left foot goes down he doesn't have the
musculature to control the left foot so
we put him in an orthotic device it's a
smart orthotic device so it's actually
going to cushion when he slaps down and
then it's gonna propel his his
locomotion for the day part of it we
actually use an adaptive biomimetic
torsional spring damper to cushion the
slap we used to minimize impedance
controller and then we're using an
adaptive torsional spring damper what
shouldn't go it's a learning algorithm
he has one good leg so he can take all
the kinematics all the body angles from
the right side and beam him over to the
left side and he would have loved to
walk right out the lab but we had him
tethered of course so
huhuhuh and his folks are actually
trying to commercialize that that
devices as we go along so how can we
help people on earth and what can we
learn from some of our extreme
environments we only get to fly an
experiment about once every decade in
space so I hang people from the rafters
and and we do things like take the floor
out from under you so sorry about that
you can volunteer to be a subject if
you'd like to come over to our lab and
what I'd like to show you here is
actually called a false platform
experiment so you're gonna see a first
jump I'm actually the subject with my
graduate student there I want to test
out all of our experiments we all have
we have human use approval for all of
our experiments I would mention so I
jump down I'm wired we're looking at all
of my muscle activity we're also looking
at the kinematics we're looking at my
body angles and now you're gonna see me
jump through the floor but I don't know
that they removed the floor I'm back
there listening to white noise now I
didn't fall which is a good thing but
we're really interested in that posture
and control again for folks here on
earth that have pathology and disease as
well as for putting people in the
extreme environments that I usually
study in space we use control theory and
dynamics models I'm not going to bore
you with that I do have a little bit of
data here don't know if you can see
there's not it's quite bright where I am
so this is muscle EMG activity an s and
neck muscle the sternal master clade the
neck muscle there's data here that shows
you the red data the neck muscle turned
off on the first jump when the subject
hit the floor it did anything but turn
off when you fell through the floor a
real heightened significant response and
here we have the kinematics of the knee
joint
this bold wavy line here and what we've
proved within the hundred milliseconds
that you fell through the floor in 70
milliseconds you flexed your knee and
then you re extended it that 100
milliseconds is much much faster than
the 250 milliseconds I need to make a
voluntary control so voluntary movement
so we prove that there's both
feed-forward controls from the brain
down
the arms and legs as well as a feedback
control so if you're an engineer like
myself you come up with an elegant model
you say Wow for the first time we've
proved this feed-forward feedback
controllers it had been done in cats and
animals before but without hurting any
of the folks just having them fall
through the floor we were able to prove
it in humans as well
I don't poke and prod I don't like blood
myself so um there's a reason I'm not an
MD I'd faint okay so as I mentioned we
have to train astronauts we do a lot of
work here on earth before we get to fly
our experiments so I'd like to show you
a little bit of what we do for some of
our training we spend most of our time
training NASA astronauts in kind of
large water tanks now take you on a ride
here I'm not trying to make you sick but
this is a full full petal payload Bay so
we go underwater on your right you see
us underwater but now we have a
treadmill and a lunar simulation that's
1/6 your body weight or 1/6 G now you're
at Mars this is 3/8 loading 3 ace your
body weight we load the person through
the center of the mass of their legs to
try to make the most realistic
simulation of the moon and the Mars that
we can now we're flying in an aircraft
this is NASA's kc-135 but we're flying a
lunar parabola and next comes a Martian
parabola it looks pretty much like
bipedal locomotion looks looks
comfortable the great thing is we can
all be marathon runners when they get
you to the Moon and Mars just a little
bit of data this is just force traces
left foot right foot left foot it's
normalized the units here are about
three in terms of ground reaction forces
when we did the Mars simulation it's
about half so it's not quite a linear
response but it is significantly reduced
that's an important part of the story
because we see significant physiological
deconditioning with our astronauts
subjects I'm going to move on to that so
what are the big challenges that we have
in spaceflight well musculoskeletal loss
is right up there at the top of our
challenges so again I've showed you some
videos in microgravity were floating
freely we're not bipeds anymore we're
kind of horizontal more like snake and
swimming type of motion but as soon as
we get to the moon 1/6 our weight Mars
3/8 our weight
maybe some things will be restored but
from our decades of microgravity work
we're really trying to do sensory motor
investigations we look at the adaptation
we look at locomotion and then we try to
tell the story about these planets we've
never been to before although we have a
little bit of lunar data so just from
microgravity long-term spaceflight now
months in space not weeks but months in
space this is data from over 30
cosmonauts and astronauts to date the
good thing is and my astronaut friends
don't like when I say this but you're
you don't you're not losing any bone
loss in your skeleton you actually are
gaining it so you a little bit
thick-skulled that would go that goes
well with the astronaut core as well as
a lot of us at MIT your arms aren't
doing too bad either
we don't see a significant loss in bone
degradation per month in spaceflight but
all the numbers in the red is what you
should be concerned about we see one and
it gets close to 2% bone mineral density
loss per month in spaceflight these are
very healthy 40 50 something year old
folks so we see muscle atrophy 20 to 30%
we see up to 40 percent strength losses
that's the good news the bad news is
that 1 to 2 percent bone mineral density
lost per month for the skeletal system
so now how many of you gonna join up for
my 4 year Mars mission this is a micro
scan of a bone for a very healthy 37
year old male this is a very unhealthy
84 year old male with osteoporosis so my
job in part then is to try to keep the
astronauts they go to Mars and the moon
not looking like this nice squatty
little gentleman down here there's a
huge relation to aging but we have some
different bone loss mechanisms so I'd
like to show you a little bit of some of
our latest data we moved to mice because
we can study a lot more mice and we can
cosmonauts and astronauts in space
there's a little mouse running over our
force plate so work of a recent PhD
graduate student Erica Wagner so we look
at the muscles we look at the bone we
see a very significant for this is a
Mars simulation we see a significant
decrease in the musculature I'm showing
you average data from the gastrocnemius
muscles so very significant bone loss
here in this study it was over 23%
that's the good news I told you about
right then now we get to the skeletal
system so let's take a look at the the
femur this is the femur here if you're
familiar and you know hip hip is up here
we'd go down the down the thigh so we're
gonna take slices and data here at mid
shaft and then down toward the distal
end of the femur
now cortical bone you need to know about
2 types of bone so cortical bone just
think about that is the the outside hard
shell of your bone so I'm just gonna
draw it here as a cylinder and our
controls should not change and then we
have a choice if we're gonna lose bone
in space our inside diameter might get
bigger or our outside diameter could
shrink or we could have both at the same
time well what's going on well from all
of our our data both in humans with some
little bit to human data and now with a
lot of data our mouse this is what's
happening the outside diameter is
actually we're losing it and shearing
down so we see about a 9% loss in the
cortical shell we have 9% cortical
thinning we have about 30% loss in the
bending strength of our Kartika shell
when you take a look at the spongy bone
the bone all these little struts that
make up the inside of your bones so
again this very healthy control bone and
then here we see about 11% thinning in
the trabeculae so we have a significant
musculoskeletal deconditioning issue
that we're trying to address we've been
trying to look at the mechanisms we're
feeling pretty good about where we are
with understanding what the mechanisms
are and so what are we gonna what are we
gonna do about it
let's just put you on a on a map here
here's Earth 1g and you go down to about
3/8 G here for what the Mars condition
is like and then the moon is about about
160 again microgravity here is something
very different I've showed you some
significant losses this is a bone loss
graph up up on the top is the cortical
bone that outer
she´ll in green and here on blue are the
more significant trabecular losses now
it's anything but linear life would have
been easy if we would have said from one
G down to spaceflight because we've been
in microgravity quite a while we see
real significant losses here there
relative changes to 1g up to 60%
relative changes it's very nonlinear and
we have this interesting potentially dip
at Mars which didn't make sense at all
you know why would we lose more
potentially at a higher gravity level
than the moon well there's different
reasons for that and it has how much
moving around or you're doing remember
those falling through the platform
experiments that I showed you there's a
posture stability if you're moving
around a lot you might actually be
helping the integrity of your
musculoskeletal system so we're really
trying to understand these significant
losses but again it's anything but but
linear and so we're really trying to get
into the details of what the mechanisms
perhaps are behind these changes that we
see just put another plot up here if you
want to take a look at spinal cord bone
loss I put this up just for reference
the first two years we see a very
significant drop-off in the skeletal
loss but then a bit of a plateau so
we're also looking for these mechanisms
from our spaceflight data in terms of
will we see a plateau will it will we
really plateau in terms of our skeletal
losses we don't know the answer to that
yet we haven't had long enough to study
it and we haven't had enough subjects to
actually fly so that's why we use the
mouse model so in one slide I kind of
have a dense summary here but to tell
you everything we know about from the
last decade or so for the
musculoskeletal deconditioning
here's the the reason we have a negative
calcium balance so per month we're
losing about a half a percent it is a
bit site-specific when we look at bone
loss especially to the vertebrae and the
longitudinal bones of the the legs when
we take a look at the biomarkers from
the astronaut cosmonaut data we see an
increase in bone resorption and then we
use our animal studies we see a decrease
in the bone formation
we good news is we see pretty much full
cortical bone recovery that outer shell
but we're not seeing the recovery in the
Trebek
bone and that's a link again to to aging
and to a bit of the mechanisms between
osteoporosis the cortical thinning again
close to 9% that's really caused by that
outside diameter becoming smaller not
the inside diameter so we see a see a
change in the outside diameter that's
different than in the case of Aging in
the natural case of aging your inner
diameter is gonna grow larger but your
outside diameter is also gonna go grow
larger so aging is actually an
appropriate skeletal response it
maintains the material properties and
the bending strength from our
spaceflight data when we look at the
trabeculae the trabecular deterioration
in terms of the bone volume over the
trabecular volume we see this 20%
Stanny 11% in the actual numbers of the
trabeculae themselves we see a
significant reduced bone formation rate
that's really due to the loss of the
mineralizing surface it's not a
reduction in the osteoblasts that's kind
of the bone building number we do see a
very significant reduction in bending
strength close to 30% in the ultimate
moment is really due largely to the
geometric changes and then in muscle
atrophy again close to the 20% and more
changes depending on what muscle you
look at now that's not just because
we're in an unloaded vironment to lower
gravity environment can't explain those
significant muscle losses so what would
we like to do about this it's
significant we the data i've shared with
you from astronauts is with exercise it
doesn't get us there some
pharmaceuticals some bisphosphonates are
promising but we're really looking much
more into assistive suits and artificial
gravity so you saw the artificial
gravity sleeper from our lab on now you
see human powered artificial gravity
this was an actually an undergraduate
project here
with students so you pedal in pedal you
never catch each other but we can fold
pull about three g's on this so actually
I was worried we're gonna fly outside
the lab there but it really works well
on the left is an assumption design if
you
well one of the ways we might be able to
address this musculoskeletal
deconditioning is actually by providing
you with with high frequency
about 40 50 Hertz would be very nice
there's some very nice work by clint
rubin and folks in new york again it's
not becoming a powerlifter
that probably won't do it for you in
space we've been doing that for decades
and we really haven't attacked this
problem but I put you on a vibrating
platform in this case we actually put
the frequency think about it as a foot
massage if you will while you're
spinning away on our artificial gravity
device that might be what we call the
ultimate countermeasure the using
artificial gravity you're basically
loading yourself you have one body
weight equivalent at your feet and if we
give you this little vibration at the
feet we might be able to really not see
any of these deleterious physiological
effects that's the hope but we still
have a lot more research to do in this
area so I'd like to move on to some
interesting environments we get to fly
with NASA so they're weightless aircraft
affectionately known by the students of
the vomit comet
this is astronaut Cady Coleman
performing our experiment with us this
is how we can truly simulate the space
environment less going with a space
flight experiment so it's a very useful
aircraft to perform our experiments in
these are smart sensors force and torque
sensors here and again you can see that
the motions are a little difficult I
kind of losing markers up there were
floating around trying to catch our
markers not an easy laboratory to
perform science fair
so that was to try to quantify the the
motions the motion strategies is it
great to do one-handed push-up so
everyone can be a here we go we're
trying to again these smart sensors
we're trying to look at different motor
control issues as well as the movement
of all the limbs and joints everyone has
little weight bags in their pockets when
you don't feel good you just you know
relieve your stomach and you just keep
going on with the experiment so uh
pretty expensive to flying this airplane
and we're you get a little bit adapted
it's always better the second third and
fourth day but um it's a little bit it's
a kind of definitely an extreme
environment to perform your experiments
in so if we get all of our science and
all of our data then usually at the end
we can have a little bit of fun up there
I obviously need to have a little better
motor control and posture control so now
what I really want to show you is kind
of the students they're kind of the
stars of the program so let me see if I
can get the you might have heard about
spheres professor Dave Miller colleague
in in aero-astro this is we just started
this as a design project for our junior
and senior engineers if we can have this
sound a little bit up on this and be
great in your new higher ease and they
said we would like to see higher ease
that have the full lifecycle experience
in developing an aerospace product we're
trying to make our conceived design
implement and operate the context of an
engineering education so we came up with
this course which is really a three
semester course and started basically
with a clean sheet of paper where we
gave them a problem something to build
give him some requirements and they took
it from there built the thing
and are now operating that facility in
NASA's zero-g aircraft the students were
presented with a basic concept and
allowed to run with it and their own
pursuits the concept is that instead of
building large expensive satellites we
can make them cheaper by perhaps
building smaller ones and coordinating
their activities on the kc-135 the real
goal is to see if we can predict how our
algorithms will work in an environment
other than that in which we designed
them so we can't do that in the lab we
can't test in zero-g but we can design
controllers go up on the kc-135 see how
they behave in zero-g and see how our
predictive capability is they did pretty
much what they were supposed to do you
lift it up and let go and it stabilizes
itself so we we demonstrated that which
was one of the goals of the of the
flights I think that we got some good
data on both with the spares doing and
on what the plane is doing because the
plane does some pretty extreme stuff and
that what the plane does also affects
how our experience works I was telling
somebody the other day that if we're in
a group walking somewhere where I have
images of the right stuff floating in
the back of my mind and everybody I tell
about the project their jaws just drop
and then he goes on to say and only at
only at only at MIT so really the
students are the the stars here this was
a really interesting educational
experiment today spheres with the pIJ of
Miller is a full-time International
Space Station experiment started really
in our laboratories with 15 brave
juniors and seniors who said let's give
it a shot we'll go from clean sheet
paper we'll work on this hard and we'll
build something and design it and and
really be able to fly it for NASA so it
was a great experience
here we are - just wanted to show you a
little bit of the some of the where
science meets engineering because we
really do want to see how the brain is
is controlling the the motion and so
here's a little bit of our approach for
motor control and adaptation for this
alternate environment
so our null hypothesis is that in our
brains and essentially we have these
internal models and feedback control to
make these sensory motor adaptations for
these altered environments so as
engineers and we apply adaptive control
models of the motor system they're very
robust they're physics-based they need
to work in a 1g environment but they
need to work in microgravity azhar
floating and we need them to help
predict lunar and Mars performance as
well they incorporate both position and
velocity feedback our latest models
actually use an unscented Kalman filter
for all of you engineers out there so
there are central nervous system motor
control models right now are accounting
for all of the system nonlinearities
their physics base just F equals MA you
never never never get to leave that and
again trying to look a little bit at it
sensory motor inputs and then we go full
circle and put some Bayesian
optimization - to take a look at the
visual motor performance we're trying we
borrow from robotics theory but we also
try to enhance a bit of the robotics
theory humans are very complicated
intimately complex well we'll hear from
our next speaker how complex robots can
be and we want to make our models is
biologically relevant we're just
touching on it of course we're not
replicating nature by a long stretch but
we're taking our engineering methodology
and trying to design these experiments
it goes from the hardware and the
software these kind of forced torque
sensor Suites
they're very modular the astronauts can
just pick them up and move more that we
want they evolved as the astronauts need
them to and then we kind of sneakily
take a lot of science in the background
as well as they're just going about
their daily business
the one of the real ideas behind here
that I'll just stop and mention is kind
of dual adaptation we think it's
possible for me to be a biped and walk
around here and be adapted but as soon
as I put you into space you're going to
bump around a little bit like you've
seen in the videos the simple example if
I were to take in them
and toss it out to you right now I would
account for a parabolic trajectory if I
were a really good baseball player I
could do that really well at ninety
hundred miles an hour but when you get
into the microgravity environment it's
gonna go in a straight line now how
quickly can my motor control and my
brain adapt to that we think it might
take about 30 days about a full month to
completely adapt to this new environment
now it takes a young child you know a
year to two years to get those motor
programs down we think with adults you
can maybe add amped on the order of
about a month and now you have
performance that's more akin to you know
an elite athlete and finally we think
that you can have no dual adaptation
that you can adapt to different
environments I'm going to keep those
motor programs in your brain and
basically turn on one if you're an
astronaut in microgravity when you come
back to earth you're gonna have to
switch back to your earth programs and
again it takes weeks to maybe a month to
when you come back to Earth to get
everything going right the the funny
things are when the crew come back you
know they're brushing their teeth and
they just let go of the toothbrush and
it falls down
you know they leave their their combing
their hair and they forget about things
because now you know boom they're back
and so they have to readapt to the
Earth's gravity field but we think that
the brain is just so beautiful and
complex we don't understand it that you
can really adapt to these very different
type of type of environments so move
along here and let's see what it take
your neck still in microgravity was one
of the hardest problems we hadn't solved
up until our most recent graduate we
just walked yesterday was had everything
to do with angular momentum and
conservation so this is a good tie into
the universe - to Max's talk as terms of
just a individual estimate now how can
he do that showed you before the
different axes because you have to
conserve momentum now in the model so
far we have about 37 degrees of freedom
in the current models we put in the
dynamics we put in the motion and then
again we're just touching the surface of
what sensory information was the central
nervous system doing to control we use
quantized and optimized control methods
and the real trick here is we can
replicate the motion and we kind of
break it down into different motion
primitives so you can spin this way and
rotate this way now why is this
important first of all for for training
again for astronauts but for hopefully
for some pathology on earth as well as
we can really break these into the
motion primitives and then once we go
into ev8 extra vehicular activity we
have our spacesuits on you're stranded
away from the craft your little jetpack
we call it the safer the jetpack doesn't
work anymore can we train someone to
make a safe return we think we can in
terms of kind of decomp decomposing all
of these motion perimeters and then
training folks into how to get get about
so we're making a lot of nice progress
and and that work and very nice work of
Leia sterling sheep she walked yesterday
with her with her PhD okay so getting
toward the toward the end of my talk and
so I want to take you into the world of
spacesuits this is just a little
infographic all these white dots up here
are the human kind
we've performed over 500 spacewalks
extra vehicle activities our first
mission to
ours is gonna be over a thousand so we
have 40 years of experience the first
mission boom so so I argue that we need
a pretty new revolutionary design we've
always flown in a gas pressure ice shell
the great thing is it keeps the crew
alive but it's not too creative I would
argue so when I talk to students about
what should the future the spacesuits
look like I had a lot of help in the 60s
look at these folks at the Applied
Physics lab in John Hopkins now who's to
say a spacesuit shouldn't be a white
spherical ball you know they don't need
to be all white Michelin looking suits
right now this is pretty creative I'm
not sure about practical but creative
he's in Apollo arms and legs are kind of
hung off this spherical shell there you
see so has pretty good flexibility in
terms of the arms and the legs he's just
going for so it's kind of a hamster cage
approach not too bad not too practical
but you know if we want to think out of
the box why don't we think of some
certain designs like this that's what I
always urge my students to take a look
at so then we moved to another what I
think was a really great idea way before
its time so now we moved to 1970 and
this is Paul Webb's space activity suit
so this was the first time that
mechanical counter pressure basically
shrink-wrapping
the astronaut was ever tried and a lot
of our work is really motivated by this
so he has a pressure suit on he's doing
all right he has a shell look at that
he's climbing up that treadmill no
problem it's pretty mobile now the thing
was this is way before we have the
materials and the analysis tools that we
have today to use because as I said this
was really in the early 70s NASA didn't
go there but I think it was a very
creative kind of revolutionary idea
really helped our work a lot so in the
lab we do do a lot of work on the
current suit current robot and current
suit we drive it with the kinematics we
we the current suit just to let you know
is a hundred and forty kilos when you're
in microgravity floating around that's
no problem
but we can't put you in a suit anything
like this when we're going back to the
Moon and Mars so we have to provide you
with maximum mobility and I want to have
minimum energy so you can really do what
you're supposed to do you're so
to be an explorer so get into a little
bit of the research then that we're
looking at again looking at the
energetics and the gravity you've seen
our our moonwalk or where we kind of
hang people from the ceiling you can
also use similar devices for spinal cord
injury to unload people to try to get
their gait patterns try to get their
gait patterns back up and going so we
look at the energetics now again this is
much more geared to the Moon and Mars
and it's this video going here again
it's in our lab we call this the the
moon Walker there's a graduate student
now the course this is it 1g it is on a
force plate again embedded with ground
reaction forces so we're taking a lot of
measurements we also take a look at the
energetics put energetics on them see
what's the cost of transport now that's
for a martian stimulation and we're
saying what's the cost of transport
that's a normalized cost of energetics
we've collected a lot of data to say how
you'll be on the Moon and Mars and then
we get into exoskeleton design can we I
don't get a spacesuit in a lab every day
so we design our our owns again another
collaboration with hue hair now see this
loping that might be the most efficient
there you go looking at all your oxygen
workload energetics it turns out you're
gonna you can all be marathon runners on
the Moon and Mars where you look at the
moon the lunar and Mars data we have a
very significant reduction here in cost
of transport and just four to six units
and joules of kilograms over meters the
1g data points are way up here
especially if you're suited so we see a
significant reduction that's very good
news we'll continue our work and looking
at suit design and the energetics that
get us there oh this one has sound so
I'm inspired definitely by The
Incredibles actually we were doing our
work before the Incredibles came along
but it's a good tagline for some of our
most recent work so the biosuit is a
mechanical counter pressure system we
actually are kind of shrink-wrapping
providing constant pressure through the
entire body and we take a systems
engineering approach we look at the
design life time the ideas it is a
custom-fit suit for everyone everyone
gets their own suit you see a couple of
our mock-ups here we have space and
Earth applications obviously
we'd love to see folks be very mobile
and be able to explore when they get to
the Moon and Mars and our most recent
project is actually looking at children
with cerebral palsy with a similar type
of smart suit for their little lower
legs because if we can put in normal
gait or normal locomotion patters when
these little folks are just infants to 2
years old again back to this idea that
they can adapt and that their brains are
very plastic and if we can provide
normal gates maybe they will have normal
more normal gait patterns for the rest
of their lives we can't cure the
cerebral palsy but we really think we
can help people move around and so we're
we're just starting to work in that area
right now some of our research results
how we I know a lot more about the skin
than anyone should for an aerospace
engineer but the last 10 years we've
been mapping the body in motion these
are some skin strain field maps on the
top or the circumferential maps going
this way on the bottom are longitudinal
maps we use a 3d laser scanner with our
folks out in Natick you get to get
dressed up and color your legs and then
we look at the movement and this is so
that we can design a system that will
give you the same stress strain profile
as your normal skin does quite a
challenge we're not quite there yet but
but we've made a lot of lot of progress
our patterning comes from some analysis
that I just have a quick little video of
here imagine if you drew circles all
over your body and believe me my
graduate students have we'd like to do
it digitally now but draw circles all
over your body and then move your arms
and legs
if you move your arms and legs those
those circles you start with your circle
it's gonna change transform into an
ellipse but watch my two red lines I
have to read bisecting diameters see
they don't change and this is an
exaggerated ellipse for just normal
human movement now just imagine you tie
all those red lines together something I
call lines of non extension probably the
collagen perhaps the collagen in our
skin might be laid down in this very
interesting pattern that is a bit
structural if that's true then I can get
the patterns for the bio
suit and that's how it's nothing to look
like a spider-man suit is to really say
that can we do we have very special
patterning because again I have to
provide 30 kiloPascals or 1/3 of an
atmosphere to keep someone alive in
space for medical applications like if
you have compression stockings or wear
this you only need it's that's easy that
you only need a tenth of an atmosphere
10 kilo Pascal's no problem that's easy
for us to do you can jump into one of my
suits here and get that but it's very
hard to keep an astronaut alive on the
Moon or Mars so we get our patterning
from some of this mathematical analysis
we're looking again for maximum ability
and trying to minimize the energy
consumption and we also need to now
we're at the point where incorporating
some active materials into the design of
our suits
kind of think of that it's kind of smart
zippers okay so we've come up with a
digital design from it's been a really
wonderful collaboration with some
international partners in Italy and and
now most recently in Portugal we're
looking at mobility locomotion
definitely inspired by designs from from
nature we go from our CAD models to the
3d human scans we corporate rate these
patterning for these lines of non
extension and just in the mock-ups as
you see up here in the stage with me
they're my size there have about three
graduate students just graduated they're
about my size as well fortunately we
have about 340 meters of that patterning
those lines of non extension in the
primary and secondary lines some of them
are biosensors as well and they kind of
take your performance your heart rate
and your metabolic expenditures as well
so some of them are smart some of them
some of the patterning or these lines
work to really provide the internal
structure if you will to carry the the
pressure wanted to spend give me toward
the end of my time and so I put in a
couple kind of outreach and educational
slides and we're excited we want to get
everyone here excited it's a great
opportunity for alum to see how can we
really send our message of science and
technology out to kids kids in the US
and worldwide so here you see something
we call the knowledge station it is well
the prototype is actually a physical
device you see one of the students in
there kind of waving your arms
it's a gestural interface and the story
is I find all kids are excited about
space exploration and so what do they
need to they're controlling an astronaut
on the screen there and if we can get
them really excited about the story
sorry about that I jumped ahead one but
the story of exploration both here
closer to home an International Space
Station going to Mars and then we go out
as far as Europa because Europa is a
really interesting moon of Jupiter to
try to look for the evidence of life and
I'll leave it to max to take us out to
the the universe but the point here is
we're trying to get out get out the kids
make it exciting and really try to
increase the the stem activities and
then getting close to the nmi Tod kind
of a just a one personal slide Garamond
I had a chance to actually sail around
the world talk about exploration in
extreme environments I think all the
colleagues thought we were nice
beautiful sunny places because you only
take pictures when you're in the Sun but
this was really a for us kind of a
personal exploration or survival we
taught hundreds of children kids usually
middle school to high school kids around
the world and we were really interested
in talking to them about exploration but
exploration by sea and space all of
these kids are kids that grow up in
Islands and they know a lot about living
in isolation living on islands and
they've really never thought of space
travel but we submitted to them that is
very similar when you're living on a
boat to people on your own you have to
have all of your supplies it's very much
like a spaceship when you have to bring
everything with you for to the moon or
to the Mars you have to have a lot of
navigation and you really don't want to
make mistakes usually don't get a second
chance so there's a video playing here
of Galatea we're in about oh I don't
know those are probably only six meter
seas not the worst can't bring the video
camera out when it gets much worse than
that so it's a nice sunny day but kind
of rocking and rolling I believe they're
off the coast of Colombia everything
broke we had to repair everything we got
it back together and the real beauty of
the trip was to meet different folks
from all over the world this is a
picture from some Kuna Indians of the
San Blas Islands and it was very
interesting
to speak with them and to learn a little
bit about their their culture so that's
kind of a personal a little bit of our
personal exploration here on earth and
then to close up my my talk I just
thought you might have some questions I
also wanted to push you a little bit
this is kind of audience interactive
participation time when I think about
where's the next breakthrough going to
come for both teaching and research
these are some of the things that that I
think about I want to give attribution
to Bob Casanova who I've had a wonderful
time thinking about this so what is
revolutionary if we look through history
genius is often in the generalities
sometimes not the details new ideas
often illuminate a pathway towards a
significant expansion of knowledge
inspiring great great leaps forward
triggering a real transformation of
intuition creative paradigms are often
simple elegant even majestic and the
result of nonlinear orthogonal
imagination so I really think at MIT we
need an environment for creativity
imagination and innovation I think we're
very lucky that we can really provide
that to our students and our colleagues
and I hope that we continue because I'm
looking for a lot more revolutionary
innovation things to come
visionaries seem to be able to
intuitively comprehend the mysterious
and the visionaries and great thinkers
that I've tried to study might have a
common trait and the ability to
transcend life's experiences doesn't
make these leaps vast intellectual
distances to set new courses so I think
it's all in our imagination and not in
intimidation in imitation sorry about
that and I'm gonna wrap up my comments
there I think I have some minutes for
questions and answers about anything
I've been able to share with you I
wanted to take you from Earth to the
Moon and Mars and then back here again
home to MIT thanks for your attention
[Applause]
well thank you so much data and your
talk generated lots of great questions
and they've come kind of in two forms
one is extended concern about what
really happens to astronauts and the
people who are in space and then also
some questions about the applications of
that knowledge back on earth so one
question is what is the mechanism that
causes bone loss in space is it lack of
exercise or is it something else and
then the question is what does that
imply for a lack of exercise for people
on earth particularly as they age I'm
gonna come out here if you don't mind I
need to stay but I'm not used to tagging
between the podiums like I'm about the
same size as a podium so here I am and
much rather interact with you so that's
why we kind of have a unique laboratory
in terms of when we go to space so the
mechanisms we see some similarities as I
said we don't have it nailed down for
spaceflight we're just getting at the
level of trying to understand is that
bone formation or is our brain shutting
off bone formation because we're flying
around now we think that that's not the
case we thought just to a year or two
ago that was the case but recently we
think that no we're still building bone
but now we have this reduced if you with
the reduced geometry if you will we're
not there's not enough surface area
there so even though we're building bone
and we're still taking away bone it's
really a resorption and a formation
issue that's going on so we see
geometrical changes that are causing
this very significant bone loss you know
a month of spaceflight one to two
percent loss and again it's it's
longitudinal so we see a lot of light
loss in the vertebrae we see a lot of
loss in the legs these are areas we're
very concerned about for Earth as well
being thick-skulled or the arms now why
would it be that we're not losing bone
in the skull or the arms well just from
seeing my videos and you're probably
seen a lot of establishes what you're
moving around you're actually very
active with your upper arms and we have
an enormous fluid shift it's all
integrated physiology that's very
complex actually so there's you know
fluid shift you feel kind of puffy faced
when you go into space so we're
unloading the legs and the spinal column
but you
you see this fluid shift in the in the
face and the brain and so maybe that
pressure it's not too unlike what I'm
trying to provide pressure to keep
someone alive
so maybe the skull and the upper body
and the arms are not losing bone because
we still have some restoration here but
definitely the lower legs and the spinal
column are losing bone so then the tie
here to earth and exercise on earth
absolutely we it definitely has to do
with you know exercise how many force
how much force one bodyweight I'm
walking around and putting one
bodyweight each step you take thousands
of steps a day so if we get less mobile
we're not doing the natural thing that
our muscles and our bones need to do to
stay rejuvenated now as we age though as
I mentioned there's there's the bones do
change but it's an adaptive change it's
actually an appropriate change but we do
become more susceptible to fracture so
if we can take a look at our astronaut
population again thinking out going to
Mars and look at risk of fracture we
hope they don't fracture they're gonna
be in a spacesuit hopefully it'll be a
lighter spacesuit if we have anything to
say about it but it's still gonna be a
spacesuit with a lot of life support on
it and if they fall down are they gonna
fracture well we want to know everything
we can about that problem because they
really actually like to say okay now at
1g can we really understand the fracture
mechanism and their fracture healing
great I think there's a follow-on
question to that and and that's how much
G would be needed to minimize or to
maintain bone density and could you
counteract it by subjecting them to
normal G levels or or higher
would that work okay someone noticed
your tag about drugs might be a solution
so they want to know okay we'll try to
try to get them so how much how much G
well you know we've evolved and
developed on this planet and in 1g of
gravity field so we're very we're very
used to that we're optimized to that
that's why I show you artificial gravity
if we recreate the 1g loading level at
your feet can is that enough we think
that would be enough but we collaborate
with with MDS
engineers because we don't know the
prescription if I gave you a half a G
half a bodyweight loading for 30 minutes
a day would that be enough to keep your
your skeletal system intact so we really
don't know what the Rx is or the
prescription yet but exercise enough is
not it for our spaceflight Astra's is
not enough we know exercise is not
enough so now there's some some drug
tests going on there's a lot of bedrest
studies going on at earth we can take
people in bed rest we can tip them down
six degrees so that you get this fluid
shift you feel kind of stuffy in the
head you're unloaded on your your feet
and your legs and then there's control
groups and then there's groups doing
exercise so that we can really know how
much you might recover so but how long
we have to perhaps use a spin artificial
gravity how much body loading we need
and how much exercise we know that we
need we're not quite there yet in terms
of the pharmaceuticals again the
bisphosphonates or the seem to be
working the best for us your process but
again it's the slightly different issue
they're probably not gonna hurt which is
good news for the astronauts but they're
not that's not the whole solution we're
not we're just not quite there yet then
I I think those are all right I think
we've got time for two more if we have
short answers so here's one or two that
go together we know that cosmic rays
destroy brain cells that helmets can't
shield how much are we accounting for
brain loss and then the other question
is is anyone working on mental health of
astronauts okay those are those are
actually two great questions thanks for
thanks for those because I'm kind of
concentrated and some of our we know the
musculoskeletal system if I had to give
you the four showstoppers for a human
spaceflight to say something as
challenging as a four year Mars mission
now that includes 600 days on the
surface of Mars radiation radiation
exposure is right up there at the top of
the list so we have to protect our crew
but I don't think we're gonna do it in
the suit we're gonna do it in safe
havens because we're really you really
need to worry about galactic cosmic rays
when you when we go out further and can
be very damaging so it's more of a
matter of designing incredible Rovers
and safe havens that you can really
because if you put all that shielding
into a suit obviously it's not it's not
mobile anymore so water is a great you
know protection for radiation so if
you're in your habitat or your Rover and
your shielded we might be able to
address the radiation issue there was a
question about mental mental health
human factors or the psychological
factors again my top four this would be
radiation would be musculoskeletal
perhaps immunology and then the social
psychology of it the psychology of the
human factors you're locked up in
something probably smaller than your
bathroom with four to six of your
favorite friends there close to four
years I mean you want to get in that
suit and go explore you are in a small
craft and NASA's done a really good job
at selecting folks but there's been
there's been some episodes and I have to
say that in the history of human
spaceflight nASA has played paid less
attention to that and the Russians paid
more attention to that they have some
early explosions physical explosions
fights things like that and said wait a
minute got the docs involved and so it
really is important to we need these
missions to be successful we really have
to look at crew selection and the best
probably way to do that is do some
analog training and so we locking people
up in boats to sail around the world
having them in Antarctic doing
exploration doing different things like
this I think is really important the
crew mix and and again their their
mental stability and working together in
teams because again they're there
hopefully if we have something to say
about it it'll be globally it'll be
world cooperation and we need to get on
with our business of exploration great
and one last question the first part of
it is do you think that human travel to
Mars is safe and practical at this time
and then the bigger question is will
humankind ever truly leave the earth or
the solar system what are the limiting
factors okay well first my person of
course we will most I think we need to I
think we're very short-sighted if we're
not going to Mars we right now have a
2030 vision for the US I hope we go
internationally it only makes sense to
pool resources in my lifetime it is
a bit disappointing to me that we were
went to the moon now was not
disappointing that was fantastic that's
probably why I'm here in front of you as
an aerospace engineering professor but
in 40 years we haven't been back that's
disappointing we have the technology we
can keep people safe the moon is only
three days away boom it's nothing is
there
Mars is tough that's what we're looking
at Mars Mars is a Mars is a step change
I'm not kidding you that Mars is
challenging significant but but we're up
to the task I know we're up to the test
we can do it with conventional launch
and rocket be nicer if we had some some
fancier propulsion systems people are
working on them a little bit and so we
can get to Mars safely I think we can
keep people alive I also think we have
to be ready to accept that maybe
everyone doesn't come back alive so
that's just the business of exploration
this area when we first went to
Antarctica and all around the world we
didn't bring back all the crews so we
have to help educate the public that
this is kind of like being a fighter
pilot a test pilot we're going to two
different places you know what's it
worth if we can really find the evidence
for the origins of life three four
billion years ago on Mars
it's huge that's huge that's a huge
thing I think that we should be up for
and go explore in terms of humans if
going by beyond beyond our solar system
I think right now I leave that to the
cosmologists I think exploring our solar
system with people and robots so this is
a great segue to the exciting talk we
have coming up it's the humans gonna be
in the loop but if I'm here at MIT or in
Mission Control or Space Station or
perhaps on Mars it's just a question of
where the humans located the human is
they're making the decisions as robots
get more and more capable than
absolutely we should be sending robots
into these extreme environments and they
can accomplish a lot but when we're
trying to find that that fossil that
shows the evidence for life I think it's
going to be human teams working with
robotics to really do the bang-up
science that that we need done and that
extends all the way out like I said to
the moons of Jupiter and beyond but
that's as far as I'm ready to send
people right now on taxpayer dollars
[Applause]